Hello, oh, oh, give me a sec loading in dokeybird loading in
all brown
Round count this in your intro data
It still counts that's right I'm stat padding they had to
count that because it's technically out of the intro So I'm
stat padding my I why my intro yap ratio that's looking
right reset the leaderboard.
They can't do it for every stream.
They're going to count whenever I do my intro and stop my
intro.
This counts.
This is out of my intro.
Count this stat, man.
Hello, hey, everybody.
I'm back for real this time.
Now he has to watch every single stream to know when the
intro begins and when it ends.
where does it start where does it begin it has to be
accurate data
i will get on top of the leaderboard any way possible i will
find every loophole every every loophole every possible meta
gaming before they patch it out.
All right.
Hello, everyone.
Let me fix this real quick.
I woke up and then my manager was like, look at all this
work you have to do.
And I was like, I'm looking.
I'm looking at all the work.
I'm looking.
Can it stop?
So I had to disappear for a second.
I'm going to adjust some stuff real quick.
All right.
I think this is good.
There we go.
Hello, everybody.
Get back to work.
Solid snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is your Oshi competitive?
Well, you see.
It's not about being competitive.
about winning cyber thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you she can't keep getting away with it alan thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you you're sally because
you didn't finish your work didn't you no oh that's not true
i just wanted to you know increase my increase my kd you
guys um no i actually did finish my work um uh like two
minutes before i start the stream uh meddy thank you thank
you thank you he's just taking out all her anger this from
silent it's a cycle thank you super chat thank you thank you
just some stuff real quick today we are gonna be playing
some more armored core uh oh my gosh sorry my cables are
underneath my chair right now and i hate that okay uh today
we're gonna be playing armor cord yes a rare dokey moment
where she continues the game after beating the first ending
but i saw so many of you guys Really, really, really,
really, really, really, really, really, really, really,
really, really, really, that's one too many reallys.
Maybe I should not do that just despite all of you.
You guys caught me at a really good mood when I made that
schedule.
Not today.
Not today, though.
If it was today, I would have been like, fuck that.
I'm joking.
But during the time I was making that schedule, you caught
me at a really good time.
So I decided to actually a very rare dokey moment.
I decided to continue a game, which you don't see often.
You do not see that often.
So, yeah, no, this is like finding a unicorn for the first
time.
And the last time, because now that's what's the last
surviving unicorn.
Now he's dead.
But you only get one chance, one choice, one option.
Um, this is your one time, the rest of my career, the one
time you get to ask me to play further than the original
ending, and you spent it on Armored Core, just so you know
that, it will never happen again.
There is one time, you're one time only on this channel, and
it will be on Armored Core, so you cannot ask me after that.
You could not ask me after that.
It'll never happen again.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Unless...
Unless via other means.
But this is the last time I'll do it for free.
You're right.
Let me rephrase that.
This is the last time I do this for free.
Money changes everything.
NSD, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Rather becoming more punctual in my ocean.
Rather mess with data gatherer.
Never change, Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
CDI, thank you for the super chat.
I will take bribes.
I'm easily corruptible.
So if you don't even have to slide it under the table,
just...
Your Oshi will absolutely take bribes to change the outcome.
And her goals and ideals are very malleable.
She is not loyal to, she's not loyal to whatever she
believes in.
She is loyal to whatever you want her to be loyal to.
See, at least I'm honest about it, you know.
yeah my morals are very very very flexible i'm very open to
anything
as long as a dollar bill is stapled on top of it all right
anyway today we're like i said we're gonna be playing armor
core uh and we're gonna try i don't you guys say it's really
fast so we'll see to get like to get to the endings because
uh We keep all our stuff, so I hope you're right, but yes,
this will be the last time, the one and only, no, not, not
the last time, but the one and only time I do this for free.
I told you, you guys caught me at a really, really good time
when I made that schedule.
My one and only free new game plus.
This is a historical moment, guys.
I spent years.
Not doing new game plus, guys.
In my entire streaming career, the dragoons can attest, the
old goons can attest to it.
They've been begging for years.
This is a historical moment right now.
You're here for this moment in time.
I played so many games.
And I've never buckled down to new games.
Game Plus.
A first time experience.
You gotta write this down in the history books.
Thank God this is recorded, guys.
Alright, let's see.
I need to remember what the sound system is for this.
Alright, 7.3.
See.
Armored core.
Alright.
Right there.
Thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
He's somewhere.
He's lost in time.
He's just in, um, on a very secret mission.
He's in a very secret mission in Africa.
Oh, they give us Super Chat.
Thank you.
Slides of five.
So what does a five get me?
A timeout.
NSD, they give us Super Chat.
Thank you.
Omni, thank you for Magenta Super.
thank you thank you got a job for you 61 new game plus let's
go fun fact walter treats you better new game plus compared
to your first playthrough why because i fucking died he's
like oh we can't let her we gotta be careful with this girl
thank you for the magenta soup also nice thank you like this
guy needs therapy we gotta be nice to him
He's like, he's scared.
He's like, oh shit, I gotta be nice to him.
He'll tell me not to show up tomorrow at school.
All right, let's see.
All right.
We're open for sponsors.
Goombat is looking for sponsors right now.
Any offers, any offers for Goombat?
Oh, do I have new parts?
I don't even know what to...
I don't know.
I love tank.
I love tanking stuff, though.
It's sponsor time.
Did I complete all?
Oh, these are... Do I have enough?
Oh, wait.
No, I don't.
I have zero chips.
I forgot I had to earn it through the... Okay, guys.
Uh... I sprained my back a little.
I slept wrong, like, uh, two days ago.
And I thought it'd be better by now.
But I sprained my muscle in the back.
two days ago.
It's getting a little better every day, but ahh, there you
go.
It's alright.
For, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
League change.
Quail, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Medi fan club is trying again to get Medi on the bot.
And ST thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Can I sponsor you to not use Big Boom in this playthrough?
You're practically asking me to fucking stop breathing.
What's wrong with me?
What?
Do you want me to just stop breathing?
Oh my god.
You want to take the fish out of the ocean?
Like what the, that's just crazy talk at that point.
Here's it.
Can you rely on your favorite, uh, favorite song from
Beatles?
Oh, what my favorite song from the Beatles?
So thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well, if it comes from, Just a World Cup, I'd say Jude.
Just from the World Cup alone.
Uh, yeah, just say you hate me.
You just hate everything about me and you don't even like
me.
Alright, um, let's see.
What do we...
I vote let the fish fly.
Frozen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Well, technically, well, has the deciding sponsor right?
right now for $20.
Going once for a Medi fan club.
Going twice.
Going three and a half quarters.
Going five out of six.
Going eight out of ten.
Going pie.
And
Alan, one at a time, guys.
Anything but many.
And a Steve, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alan, thank you for the magenta super.
All right, well, I'm so sorry, Quill.
I tried so hard to make sure you get it.
But unfortunately, the dragons were so...
so fast with the other dragoon um auction uh people at the
auction were so fast that they took they sniped your spot
right from other you there was no way i could react to it
quill i was so fast with this too wow you guys were snipers
this is not good i hear my bad quill from using the ip Many
IP for low-falling the sponsor.
Many, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, my God.
They were so fast, guys.
It was like 90 miles per hour type snipe right there.
Like, that guy was already...
They loaded the sniper rifle and go, pew!
And then, whoa, right from under me.
It was gone.
The sponsor, your sponsor, just disappeared.
I know oh like I I blinked and then it was gone it was crazy
what thank God we caught it on tape to see how fast that was
it was like like 0.1 frame you know there was no frame like
there was no lag or anything oh my god it was one frame
I'm Chicano thank you with super chat thank you thank you
they didn't snipe that at the last minute I was very close
to throwing in steam that's a sponsor i know it was just wow
jacquard thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh
all right anything but menu so anything will be frozen's i
don't know what the context is so i'll just put frozen's
frozen's fan club all right let's see image and oh my god
that's a lot of words we'll just put frozen's you know what
that's on you for not specifying what you want in your bid
like i'm just gonna do whatever it says on the bid itself
and it's just frozen that's what you wanted right should
have been specific it's the auction
oh i let the fish fly quail spawn or labeport sudoki get
more soup as evil alan thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you oh it's oh it's let the fish fly I'm sorry not
don't fry the fish fly all right you'll be blue okay we got
fish ready all right we got fish and then we got copy that
confirm
where the fuck is the copy copy it let the okay there's two
F's two whoa whoa whoa oh let's live okay let's do this guy
let's this little guy's a little funky right now okay l
where the heck am i gonna get an l there we go all right
let's okay there's one oh wait there's two l's there's two
l's okay lie all right we got two l's now we need an E.
E.
Let.
And then we need a T.
Oh, there's a lot of T's here.
That's good for me.
T.
Okay.
Let.
And then I love my serial killer fonts.
That's when you know I'm a very stable mercenary.
Okay.
Uh, yeah, very stable.
Did not kill the entire universe for money.
Nope.
H.
A.
Offerad, there is a.
ransom no i hold the universe hostage again that's right you
think i will do it i'm crazy enough to do it again all right
let's see we gotta put that in jacquardo thank you for super
chat thank you thank you that's right have you seen me in
the zodiac killer in the same room all right uh
all right we're almost done
And...
But maybe that's why I always... I've been... I'm still
doing armor core streams.
Long-term investment.
I actually didn't realize that.
I just figured... I just noticed it now.
My long-term investment, guys.
So I'm playing the long game.
There's still add space on the robot.
If there's still add space on the mecha, there's gonna still
be armor core streams.
This looks like a ransom note.
I'm holding the universe hostage again.
All right, let the fish fly.
The sponsors are too profitable.
There's always going to be a sponsor.
Alright.
Wait, wasn't there a stream that was originally sponsored by
Dragoon?
Did I ever do that stream?
Did I...
Did I just remember...
Did Dragoon sponsor a stream in the...
Did I ever do it?
Did I...
Yeah.
Who sponsored a member stream and then I took it down.
No, not Baldur's Gate 3.
There was another.
I know about that.
I'm planning that.
It's not Baldur's Gate 3.
I'm thinking about another stream.
I'm thinking, that's still in the works.
But I'm thinking about another, the other stream where I put
their names in the description.
And then I changed the game and I deleted them.
No, not that one.
You know the one in the member stream?
Where I...
Where I put someone in the description.
Like, I'll be like, sponsored by this dragon.
And then I change...
Oh, we don't talk about that one.
Which stream was that?
I just remembered that.
Papa Smurf.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
NASCAR walked so dokey.
Good run.
I even think you was super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, it was StarCraft Broodward.
Thank God you just remembered.
Thank you.
It was Super Chat.
Oh, it was for the aisle.
Oh, yeah.
I replaced it with the aisle.
Oh, because, like, he made the title.
I don't remember.
I'm so sorry.
I don't remember what the title was.
He sponsored the stream because he came up with the title.
And then Yeah, no.
Apparently there was a lot of things that got spot.
Don't worry.
They're all in the works, guys.
They're all in the work.
Did you guys, does anyone remember?
Does anyone remember the title of that stream?
Guys, does anyone remember the title of the James Bond
stream?
All right.
Yeah, okay, we're gonna decal.
All right, where do we put this guy?
Decal.
You know what?
Put it on the head.
I realize because...
Oh, wait, I will put this on.
Wait, no, no, this should be on the head.
Okay, now, after that...
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, no, that's just...
Okay, yeah, this should be here.
And then on the head...
should have it here and then and we'll position you right
here let the fish fly sponsored by iphon and frozen all
right don't worry it's not a scam if I eventually do it he's
got to be patient guys there's a lead-up time you You know,
it's one to two business years.
Yeah, but you gotta be patient, guys.
You read, someone didn't read the terms of services when
they put on the bid.
All right.
Sorry, Alan.
Sorry, your names both start.
Your names both start.
Your names are both so similar and start with A.
You share at least one letter.
Anyone could have been confused with that, guys.
It's an honest mistake.
Your names are so similar.
You share at least one letter.
It's an honest mistake.
Anyone could have made that mistake, guys.
Absolutely anyone.
I guess it can't be...
I mean, in fact, it's your fault for both...
Start having the letter A's in your name.
This should be, like, username thing.
Like, username rules.
But, like, every time you take a letter, you can't have that
letter at the same place anymore.
Hold on now.
Where do you mean there, Paul?
All right, give me a sec.
I just got a...
Oh, did you guys hear?
Uh...
Did you guys hear how...
Um, 2XKO is shutting down?
Which is crazy.
The game literally just came...
Like, it just came out this year, right?
Yeah, I just saw, like, Twitter announcement that they are
shutting down.
Um...
They're shutting down 2XKO by the end of the year.
Yeah, it hasn't even been...
Oh, yeah, it hasn't even been out for a year.
Yeah, so the last live update for 2xKO is going to be at the
end of this year.
So like December or something is the last live update.
And then they're still planning on keeping the servers, but
obviously at that point it's just dead.
Yeah, it's just there.
I think it's just because like fighting games are sort of
like dying down in NA in general.
Like I think like fighting games right now are being like
upheld by Europe and Europe and Asia but like in NA I feel
like everybody's not really like there was a peak in
fighting games but I felt like now it's like sort of dying
down a little bit in NA it's
just not the the hit trend right now I think but then like
the thing is there were like there's so many fighting games
I think even like token was it called the Marvel token game
apparently it's like super buggy on PC released because with
anti with the anti cheat and the lag and everything that
people are now parsecing uh token instead of like playing
the live version of it on pc yeah marvel token
i heard about that one yeah apparently it's like really
badly optimized and and it's like very heavily favored for
console so they have to crack the game and packs parsec the
cracked version uh and well i don't know but it's like even
the invincible game died up pretty quickly.
I don't know about the avatar game.
Also, I need to refill my water, guys.
Give me a sec.
Let me get water real quick.
And I'm back.
Also got myself.
Some chocolate blanc along the shot.
But it really expects all their spin-off games to do so well
as league and team fight.
They real forgot about Herbstone.
Yes.
There's another game that's dying in the ditch right now.
To be fair, Hearthstone had its time.
It sounds exotic.
It's one of my favorite Japanese snacks.
I haven't had them in so long.
Oh yeah, it's Blizzard.
Sorry.
I got confused because apparently they had Team Fight
Tactics.
TFT.
Sorry.
For some reason, I keep...
thinking Herbstone is Riot for some reason um because like I
got yesterday um one of my friends was playing Herbstone and
I was just like oh my god I haven't heard that game in so
long and then they said they added tft mechanics to Herbst
like that's how long I haven't heard that game I haven't
heard Herbstone in so long I thought it was from a different
like different dev company
you know you're like you haven't heard about this game and
you just thought oh shit that's from league right i feel
like i've never heard someone said they they're playing
herbstone in fucking years and then yeah but then they my
friend was like um my friend was saying that they added tft
mechanics to herbstone i guess to like do something with it
Oh, shit, because they're...
Oh, wait, was it made by...
Um...
Was it made by...
Right?
Don't remember.
It's been 20 years since I've heard someone talk about
Herbstone.
So what did they say when... He said they added...
Um...
What did they say they added to it?
They added Um...
Herfstone.
There's a TFT mode.
Oh, yeah.
There's a TFT mode?
What the fuck does that mean?
So you buy units and they fight automatically now.
So I never really played Herfstone.
I just knew it was a card game.
But apparently that's what made it similar to...
Well, that's what they did to make it more...
I guess more TFT-like.
But that isn't Herfstone anymore!
Well, well, there nobody's playing Herbstone Right now They
gotta do something
Jikado, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you At
this rate, Doki is gonna have dragoons Fight over which
dragoons get what unique first letter is a part of their
name with that I said I claim J Thank you for the super
chat, thank you, thank you Alright, here we go back at it do
i change all right guys do i re um what's the word reimagine
myself it's it's summer vacation we got it it's summer
vacation guys this is i say a summer vacation just ended
it's the time of year that we gotta reinvent ourselves lose
weight learn how to do makeup get abs before school starts
guys and then we're gonna be so on the first day of school.
Everybody, this is the year of change.
This is the time.
Some vacation is the time to change.
So we're going to be so popular on the first day.
All right, guys.
Do we change your parts or do we stay the same?
And we learn to love ourselves.
so deep.
Do we reimagine ourselves or do we learn to love ourselves
for who we are?
Self-hate!
New build.
We want to be popular!
I'm gonna get a job loose.
Wait and get a maiden.
Are we going to get that new surgery that will let us walk?
Suffering builds character.
Embrace and change.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
I'll have a list.
I'll give you guys a poll.
All right.
Hate our body.
Or learn to love ourselves for what God gave.
us all right
wait let me finish our pool and
here we go
there we go here's the pool it's not bias whatsoever.
Hate our body or learn to love yourselves for what God gave
us because we're all beautiful in the inside and out.
so which one is it, guys?
Hate our bodies and change for others.
Guys, this is totally not a biased poll or anything.
With no contest, this poll is crazy.
It says a lot about society, doesn't it?
In our armor core stream.
We learned so much about society today.
Plastic surgery is a booming business for a reason.
Is it really time, guys?
Is summer vacation where we finally get plastic surgery?
Nothing wrong with self-improvement.
Make the best of what God gave us.
Take yourself now so you can love yourself in the future.
Okay, that's good.
That's a good one, though.
It's time, guys.
On my sweet 16, my parents said they'll pay for my plastic
surgery.
Oh my god, finally, finally, now Troy will notice me.
Solid, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Totally didn't spend all the time thinking about this topic,
but the deleted sponsor title was James Guy.
Oh, wait, wait, who was it?
But does anyone remember who came up with that title?
Who paid for that title?
I like how we're like, don't worry to that dragon.
stream will next stream will will play James Bond and it
hasn't the next stream still hasn't happened yet I
mean all right I'll give you guys five more seconds actually
10 more seconds I think that's enough time I don't worry
it's a work in progress everything is all underworks guys
James Bond will come back in Avengers Doomsday which will
come first GTA 6 or James Bond all right 10 9 8 7 are you
really gonna let the haters win going to six, five, four,
three, two,
one, zero point nine, zero point eight, zero point seven,
I'm practicing for tomorrow, guys.
I'm practicing for tomorrow's Capcom quiz.
0.6.
Show us the numbers to keep.
0.5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
All right, 5.
We'll hate our body and change for others.
Jakarta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
I hate my body, but I change for myself.
We must go stronger, dragon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fine.
All right.
What do you guys want?
Well, the first stop, we got to change the legs, right?
Got to change the legs.
Oh, my gosh.
Guys, the surgery was a success.
All right.
all right what are we looking at guys what the fuck is that
a ship special take one from one tank to the other i get to
choose let's see it that is hover you can kind of fly what
the fuck do you mean by kind of fly You either fly or you
don't fly.
You know what that?
Oh my gosh, this reminds me of a certain character, of a
character.
Like, something I saw before.
I'm trying to remember.
Was it a transformer?
I'm...
I've seen this build before.
I'm trying to remember from what?
Like, from a show?
From a video game?
I've seen this.
It looks like it's above average.
But, what, what, it's, was it from a show?
I've seen this before.
Like, I've seen this silhouette before.
I don't know, from a game, from a show, from a movie.
What was this?
Something had this before.
Oh my gosh, I know I've seen this.
I just don't know from what.
I don't know, guys.
So many choices.
So little time.
The race car looks cool.
Oh, the actual hover tank filled this.
Must have been, I don't know, it was from some mecha show.
I know I've seen this design before from something from a
different eye.
I just cat for the fucking life of me remember where like
I've seen this design for a mecca slash robot there's so
many robot shows above the boat is cool all right what does
this look like what the fuck squish it you know what I'm
doing it that's right I did it from one One tank to the
next.
The assembly.
Bam!
No!
Yeah!
Alright.
I think that's good enough.
We did it, guys.
We blinged out our wheelchair.
Who could have foreseen this?
Tank built!
Bosh the surgery.
Um, I think it's an improvement.
The ladies love it.
I got a cooler wheelchair now.
That's right.
My above average wheelchair.
Oh yeah, what do we want?
Okay, I'll buy one weapon.
Is that your tank or you just happy to see?
Oh, this guy gets it.
This guy gets it.
I don't even know what my weapons are anymore, honestly.
I don't even know what I use.
Alright.
What do we get?
We'll change one weapon.
Yeah, I'm a sure.
I got the best of both worlds, baby.
Laser lance?
What's that?
in here we have oh sweet 16.
what the fuck the guy just died wait we gotta get sweet 16.
we actually got
i should don't know if wait is there sweet 16 on my right
arm there is okay i'm just gonna buy that nsd thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you from two not working legs
and getting a third leg.
That works too well.
NSD, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's right.
Happy birthday.
What is summer vacation, guys?
We gotta be dressed to the best.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, let's see.
Assembly.
I legit don't even remember what weapons I have in my arm.
That's... What is that?
What weapon is that?
Let's do...
All right, deploy me into that testing area to the practice
range.
I legit don't remember what my weapons are.
Okay, the pile bunker.
All right, that.
All right, boom.
All right, pulse.
All right, well, I don't like that.
All right, which one is which?
All right, this is...
Pulse.
All right.
So, that, wait, is that the songbird?
Which one is that?
Was that the songbird?
What is the songbird, right?
Oh my god, they all look the same to me.
They're all...
Makishima, thank you for the rage.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you had a good stream.
Okay, the sun needle.
All right.
That's my Oh wait Oh wait that's the stun needle Do we keep
Needles goaded Not all big booms are created Equally That's
the power bunker Wait is that no Yeah that's the power
bunker And then this We'll use Sweet 16 Okay And then Okay,
there's the shotgun.
All right, we got the shotgun now.
All right, my new weapon.
Okay, let's see.
Am I flying?
Does it look like I'm flying?
Can I hover?
I'm gonna guess.
Wow!
All right, we should be good.
Oh my god, I do hover.
Oh my god.
Wait, this changes everything.
We're shotgun in the game.
All right, I knew change was bad.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I...
Never change.
Stick to what you know.
I don't remember which one was the better.
Bazooka.
This?
No, it was the next one.
I knew it.
I should never never go out of the status quo.
Change is bad.
Wait, which one was the better one?
I can't remember.
this one has this one has more attack power was it the gold
chin or the javelin alpha Zimmerman's rock I'll have the
Zimmerman I'm poor I say with my six million dollars I guys
I'm saving for it for the next armor court it was a javelin
alpha all right
Now you're speaking my language.
Like, why didn't you start it off with that, guys?
Oh my god, you know I'm a meta slave.
All right, Zimmerman.
Where does the Zimmerman reside?
Okay, there it is.
I think that's the arm I needed on.
Yeah.
Now you're speaking my language.
Now you know Doki speak.
It was so simple.
You just string in all the...
All the key words.
What's...
What's the word called?
Like the...
Is it...
Ah...
Not key words.
But all like the...
You know how when you're doing a speech or something, you
have to hit all the keywords or stuff like that to make
people want to buy?
Make people want to listen to you?
The proper tags die.
What is...
words yeah yeah link all the buzzwords together bro meta
yeah you all get all the buzzwords in
for doki speak all right i think we got it we're good now
after an hour we can start our first mission is this a
choice destroy all rubicon liberate oh my god we're back in
chapter one oh my god it's sure we're rewind time.
Got a job for you, 6-2-1.
It just met us.
Oh my god, one last job.
Got a job for me.
It's the same thing, right?
It's been so long since I've been in chapter one.
This quest comes from our affiliate, Duffang.
The Rubicon Liberation Front has deployed Bios artillery
throughout the contaminated city.
The city itself has no strategic value.
You have to make sure you pick all the missions you didn't
do.
You have to make sure to remind me to pick all the missions
I didn't do.
Why don't you think I remembered?
Even you have to make sure I picked the missions I didn't
do, guys.
Yeah.
too much confidence in my ability to run for what missions i
picked three months ago
the client doesn't care who does this job all right here we
go as long as it gets done
to the bond everybody oh this is very familiar but now now
i've came back from plastic surgery artillery placements but
now i have my summer bot
guys it's different now i got my summer bot
to show off my enhancements guys i also sort of forgot how
to play the game again how could this happen again
Alright.
Whoops.
Oh my gosh, dude.
He's looking a little different today.
Is it the hair?
Guys, how do I do this shield again?
I don't remember this.
It's fine.
These guys do nothing.
Okay, I realize...
What the fuck?
Why are they so strong?
All right, there we go.
Is it control R?
Okay, it's control R.
Where's the final site?
Oh, it's over there.
Oh,
it's hit from behind guys.
It's been a while since I've been in this area.
You think your tiny little missiles are gonna scare me?
Yeah, my wife was a Dark Souls boss.
This is nothing.
Oh, shit.
Okay, maybe I should heal.
That's right.
Alright, give me a sec.
I need a repair kit to remain.
Guys, I'm just trying to get used to all these guns.
all right last one it's fine i'll tank the last couple of
hits here and then what the fuck my Zimmerman is so oh wait
there's one more over there fuck
all right give me a sec i'm just gonna hover down oh it
recharges fast at least and now just there we go
We did it, guys.
It's so easy.
Oh, it's close range.
I should remember that it was a shotgun.
See, guys, this is why I need you to remind me of missions I
did not pick.
This is the classic case of you guys have to tell me which
one is it.
I already forgot it was that I was holding a shotgun.
I literally bought the gun like 10 minutes ago.
Yeah, guys, you got to understand the pharmacy didn't have
my medication.
Oh, yeah, I should order food for lunch.
Got a job for you, 621.
It's an open call from the Archivist Group.
Another job?
One of the extra-planetary corporate forces.
Guys, you got to write sticky notes and then put it around
the...
We got momentum this, guys.
The operation will take place in Grid 135, Southern...
rebellious.
Your objective is to destroy an MT squad sent by Daphon, a
Balaam company.
3-5 is a key foothold in Archibus's efforts to conduct a
coral survey in the contaminated city.
You, the independent mercenaries, are the key to maintaining
our lead in the coral survey race.
Okay.
The Archibus group looks forward to news of your success.
Yeah!
Breathing over.
And happy hunting.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I got this it's like riding a bike but i'm in a car now it's
that easy it's just like the same thing
yeah it's like so riding a car no it's like riding a bike
but you're in a car so it's almost the same and it flies
It's literally the same thing.
It's like riding a bike, but you're on a wheelchair.
Yeah, it's cooler.
It's cooler than a bike.
Alright, let me try my shotgun this time.
Did I do it?
Guys, I don't know about the shotgun thing.
Seems pretty weak.
Am I just not shooting it?
Okay, alright, now it, okay.
Sorry, I have to make sure how to shoot this thing.
Oh my god, it's like one shot, too.
Alright, give me a second.
I'm gonna try this out.
Okay, never mind.
I just have to be, like, in there, fucking...
faces.
Where's the last guy?
Where are you?
Hello?
Oh, there you are.
Sorry, you guys were so insignificant.
I didn't see you.
Archivist really scored this time.
It's a shock.
I don't know.
I was raised on big booms.
I expected a bigger boom.
What else did you...
What else do you think I wanted?
There we go.
6-2-1, wait.
I'm picking up new enemy signatures.
Looks like reinforcements.
Eliminate them.
I think I did it.
Alright.
Nice.
There's no way.
There's no way he is behind this tiny pipe.
There's no way my $80 million dollar gun funded by the
government can't destroy a tiny little pipe.
That's it.
I stab you.
This fucking rusted little pipe thing that he just stood
behind.
It's Doki it's military grade.
He's wearing missile proof armor.
apparently there
we go another mission successful oh shit all right what does
my manager message me uh all right nest okay it's not that
important all right let's see i don't know if i like the
zimmerman honestly but maybe i just need to get used to it i
don't know okay there's one thing i don't know if i want to
do the needle i like the double booms but like i'm just so
used to the double booms you know what we'll do we gotta
start to change gradually guys i i realize i realize we
gotta do it gradual change booms cost money I'm a
millionaire Money's not the issue right now In game In game
In game In game Umbra Thank you for the super chat Thank you
thank you Just started watching you Your armor cover boards
are 8 plus good times Also give the laser lens a try It's
fun and easy I mean like oh yeah I have tried to Uh the
laser lance but i can try it again i guess because we're we
don't like it's easy right now so there's no like big boss
boys here to fuck me up so oh wait oh wait laser lance no
i'm thinking about the way moonlight blade the one i have to
fight like 20 cent in gears for laser lance oh you mean
moonlight it's almost the same thing guys they're both our
blades so technically i am
weapon all right do we these are not uh okay destroy all
robicon liberation front helicopters based on number of
enemies destroy the diving core industry tester we'll do
this first
they're both lying i know what elances they're both lying
it's the same thing
It's close enough.
This request comes from Dafa, one of our affiliates.
The group has committed to use of military force to
handle...
They're long and pointy.
Ha ha ha ha.
Target for this mission is a squad of transport choppers.
Destroy them.
You'll encounter guerrilla resistance from Bouse Mass
Produce MTs.
They're no great concern.
This is like a little bit like a recap for me.
Because I sort of don't remember what happened earlier.
early game this has been pretty much that's me raven oh does
i have to like reclaim my identity again
all right here we go now they're asking for you by name
keep building your rep yay rebuilding my reputation rewind
time oh that part was skipped That's right.
I don't need to reclaim my name.
I am.
I am Raven now.
See, sometimes identity theft works.
Whoops.
I mean.
I mean, whoops.
Whoops.
Oh, oh wait.
Yeah, for that.
This has a bit of a long range too, which is nice.
Every...
I get money from killing.
I think I could lose more money killing.
I might actually lose more money trying to kill.
I wouldn't be mad at my big booms.
Alright, nice.
Alright, we gotta kill this thing too.
by killing things even though I'm pretty sure that's not
true oh it's zero dollars oh I like the sound of that you
know what all right next one apparently this is free whoops
whoops I'm so many long rage guns I keep forgetting that
give me a sec I'm gonna use my Free weapon.
Looks like they've got a mouse, Tetrapod.
Yeah?
They did get- have one.
Yeah.
This is the- the best defense you have to offer!
This right here!
Clearly they didn't jokey proof this.
Nice.
I am.
It's like I played these games before.
Give me a sec, recharging, recharging.
Oh, yeah.
I think if I ever, if superpowers were real, I think it's
like having the knowledge of what you've done and then being
able to like reincarnate.
Like the Isakai shows and being able to reincarnate, you
have the knowledge of what you have.
have all right nice
oh i can charge i forgot about the charging part one new
message
oh yeah and also like invest in amazon and bitcoin and
google and then get assassinated because she knew too much
your actions are only helping the corpse with their invasion
it's just a job six two one that's right Of course.
I like mercenary money.
Alright, sorry.
I don't know if that guy was AI.
Or, like, if he's in his own little world.
Like, his own...
He built his own little...
Schizo world in his mind right now.
And he thinks he's watching it.
Like, in his head he's watching a different stream.
Like, his eyes are showing a different thing than what he...
What he's actually playing.
Like...
The laser lens is like power bunker, but easier to land.
And thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I was like, are you okay?
Okay, now.
Now, Kevin, are you?
Kevin, are you okay?
That guy was like my other streamer.
And now he's like, I want what that guy's having.
Kevin he was like trying to piece together the stream that
the other guy was watching
all right destroy the tester AC mods get the gun ready I
don't know about Kevin it's like letting the one guy who got
bit by a zombie in he's like I swear guys I haven't been bit
guys it's I just tripped and scraped my knee Yeah, got it
ready.
We don't know if he got bit.
Daphon, one of our adversaries allied with Balaam, has
introduced a new tester AC.
It's a sample model from an external architect featuring
extensive assembly optimizations.
In the hands of an experienced pilot, it will pose a threat.
Oh, Kevin's awfully quiet now.
The Archivist group looks forward to news of your success.
Kevin's awfully quiet now!
Briefing over.
And happy hunting.
Wait, I for real.
I swear to God.
I didn't get fit.
The target made me a product sample, but it's still an AC.
Stay sharp, 621.
Alright.
No problem.
I got this.
I can do it again.
Rewind time!
Oh god, I get to kill the little kid again?
That's right, little kid.
I got Ferrari now too.
Is that him?
Sorry, I ran out of gas.
Where did you go?
Little kid.
Yeah, I am.
Welcome to the real world, trainee.
Oh, you're so lucky I didn't bring the pal bunker.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I got you a few hits.
You know, I felt bad for you.
Yeah.
I just wanted to call Sino-Royal.
Oh, you wanted to call Sino-Royal?
been bedded guys bye look we got survival the fittest if we
let it if we let that kid live he's just gonna make weaker
kids it's called survival of the fittest guys oh yeah i also
got his money yoink took your lunch money too
All right.
Bye, little kid.
Bye, little boy.
Michigan.
About leaving 621 with the red guns.
Handler Walter.
Forgot to mention something.
You're so lucky I didn't have a pile bunker.
I've been cozying up to independent mercs.
Great news.
If it means more work for 621.
They could try whatever tricks they want.
Robo, thank you.
Thank you.
All
right, next up.
Next mission!
We're speedrunning.
Why don't I get my wife back?
Speed running to my wife right now.
The tester AC you downed.
That was being shipped to the Red Guns.
Balaam's in-house AC squad.
Their Balaam's main force, and its members are no amateurs.
Remember who you're messing with.
What do you mean?
He got DPS diff.
Triff stayed against practice versus AI.
That's on him.
Destroy the weapon.
Oh my god, I remember that.
I'm going to keep that for last.
I did not have...
Well, I was going to say I did not have fun with that
mission, but that mission was a lot.
It was a lot of stuff.
You're joining an operation planned by Baylam HQ.
Check the briefing.
Good.
Sit your ass down and listen.
Balaam's moving in on the Gallia Dam complex.
One of the Liberation Front's bases.
The objective is to destroy their lifeline and make those
sacks a shit big for mercy.
Oh, this has a choice?
Which one was the choice?
You?
You're just gonna be tagging along on ass wiping guns.
duty i'm assigning you the call sign gun 13 a lucky little
number that just became available good 13 sound off see it
is very obvious what choice did i make all right
oh okay so it's a very obvious choice completely oh do i
have to kill my friend that must be the
13 huh i'll stick with 621 don't let the red guns do yeah 61
is a higher number which means higher equals better
i'm still thinking about that kid guys should get good i
remember was there something in my back no not that mission
that's i will 100 miss it you gotta hold my hand guys if you
don't want to yell at me You got prevent that from
happening.
You got change the cat in events
Oh shit what the fuck happened
Oh my god these guys actually did so much damage on me
accidentally Why don't you start a sewing club together?
I was gonna say, where the fuck is my team?
Alright.
Gotta get to these guys.
Nice.
Two down.
That's this guy just sat in there.
I can't say I considered you a pro either.
We don't need backseat drivers and the red guns.
So I do.
I do.
Yes.
I love backseat gaming.
I'm not like other streamers
I live off back to gaming Oh wait that's new Wait what Our
request is simple We want you to take out the two red guns I
fucking knew it The compensation will be double I fucking
knew it I killed my demons why I knew it Interesting your
call 621 because i mean she's he oh your cooperation is
appreciated raven i mean he literally said i'll give you
more money
i fucking knew it guys he said i'll give you more money he
said the buzzwords guys that God knows how to do jokies
speak.
He knows jokies speak right there.
He said more money.
I said, okay.
No hesitation.
He doesn't know yet.
He doesn't know I'm going to betray him.
When he uses heal.
Guys, I don't know what's going on.
I got hacked.
Guys, don't shoot back.
I just got hacked.
Oh my god, it's such a shame guys like my my meds not
working guys.
I'm hacked
It's so unfortunate I don't know what's going on
Okay, that's actually pretty bad because that oh shit what
did I got stun blow I got stunlocked!
I was pressing C!
I was a missing button.
Alright guys, now that I know I'm fighting, I'm sorry,
moonlight.
It's time to bring back the piled bunker.
Drain, thank you magenta soup, thank you.
Guys, I got guys, guys, guys, I got hacked, guys.
I'm so impressed by this game.
Whenever I see any face, only voices.
But this game still has the best girl from any game this
decade.
G1, Michigan.
Followed close by Iron Rusty.
You guys just have a girl who helps you as much as Michigan.
Hypes G13.
He's still thinking about her to this day.
Drey, thank you.
Magenta, Supa.
Thank you.
Ava, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Mistake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Who is best boy?
If not rusty, you're wrong.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you guys I miss my wheelchair
Guys I miss my wheelchair All right, I'm ready
Yeah, he does it yo They bought you out, didn't they?
No.
I'm just hacked, guys.
Oh, my God.
Don't shoot back.
They hacked my system.
Oh, my God.
He's so fast.
Maybe it was a bad idea.
I had to stun him first.
Guys, I'm just missing.
It's because I'm missing one more boom.
I need another boom it's because of the lack of boom oh my
god we can block that but we're all right what's going on
what's going on oh I did better with the moon like oh no
it's not fair he can think how a wheelchair it's not fair
that's it that's fucking it where's my wheelchair
Change is bad.
Never change who you are.
Love yourself.
You're beautiful.
Inside and out.
True.
You remember the line?
I could target this mission and lead them over that and have
it help you.
Or if they give a super chat, they can thank you.
Changes the mistake.
Love yourself now.
Oh my god, I'm so fast.
Alright, watch this, guys.
Wait, where is he?
No!
Okay.
Five.
Boom!
Change is bad!
That's right, you just watched your friend die!
Wheelchair on Wheelchair Violence!
Yeah, treat!
It's on fair ground!
Changes!
Oh, shit!
Change is bad!
Oh, I missed that.
That's awkward.
Love yourself Now
It's 5 He said He gets stunned here
Love yourself Now Oh shit I gotta love myself here too Yeah
Yeah!
Here we go.
It's not easy.
Wheelchair on wheelchair violence is equal.
It's not a hate crime.
We're both in wheelchairs.
I told you guys.
It's like walking again except my legs don't work.
It was just that easy.
You'd fight better.
You'd spend less time thinking of one-liners.
I still won!
I still won.
One new message.
I hate that she's proving we were wrong.
You got lucky, Merc.
So, you got a nice punch in.
Go buy a lottery ticket.
are going to be first over the wall have fun watching from
the sidelines that's right a win is a win yeah i'm having
fun i beat a guy up in a wheelchair
all right destroy all right now we're back here
got a job for you six two one this one's a request from the
archivist group i didn't even need need for him.
I didn't have to leave them anywhere.
This request comes from Schneider.
I want a 2v1.
The mission will take place in the Bonadilla dunes of
Western Belias.
Our coral investigation there is being copied by the
Strider.
The other guy with glasses.
The Liberation Front mining ship.
You are to destroy it.
The Strider is a mobile resource base that was extensively
weaponized by the Liberation Front.
Call it the crowning glory of their efforts to militarize
into an anti-corporate force.
Did it work?
Your attack will focus on the eye.
A giant laser cannon connected directly to the main
generator.
It's protected by a shield, which is powered by auxiliary
sub-generators.
These should be your first targets.
This concludes the briefing.
All right.
I hope it has wheelchair accessibility.
That's...
Oh, man.
Oh, there's the wheelchair accessibility on this ship.
Yeah, it's the huge boss.
And Archibus HQ will be sure to remember your name.
They will?
Oh my gosh, I'm so famous.
Oh my gosh.
Yippee!
Alright, I don't remember where he is.
Okay.
I remember I walked away from it the first time I did this.
All right, get through all that dust and make contact with
the Strider.
I get through all that dust.
I'm almost there.
There you go.
Who's trying to shoot me?
I'm trying to try to Uber over to the big guy.
Oh shit.
I couldn't make it.
Two repair kits remaining.
All right.
That's all right.
We're almost there.
Is that over there?
All right.
Remember how to do this one.
Take out one of its legs and bring it to home.
Okay, I gotta take out all.
It was, guys, it's not wheelchair accessible.
Guys, I don't know if it's wheelchair you're accessible.
That's dumb.
I get it?
Oh, I did.
There we go.
That should be it, right?
If only I could fly.
How is I supposed to know it's not friendly to words?
wheelchairs.
How do I get up again?
Oh, okay.
Oh, oh!
Timber!
Oh my, oh my god.
It's the Prometheus.
I almost did the Prometheus thing.
I almost.
I almost Prometheus did.
We're fine.
We're okay.
I almost.
Almost doesn't mean it did happen.
Oh, man.
If only I could lie.
Oh, great.
It would be nice.
Oh, shit.
These guys don't do jack shit anyway, so it should be fine.
All right.
We all figured this out.
How was I supposed to know it wasn't wheelchair accessible?
How?
There was no cues whatsoever.
Oh my god, I don't like it up there.
There was no signs.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, I mean, that works.
Two to go.
None.
I thought they would have ramps and elevators.
The government won't like this.
I'm going to report you for discrimination.
Oh, what?
How do I get that?
Oh, here you go.
Alright, nice.
Okay, it's not good.
I really lost half my HP.
The one stab.
Okay, just in case.
You know what?
I'm fine.
Oh, shit.
You've got the target in your sights.
What do you mean?
It's fine.
There's no way you can shoot me all the way up here.
Oh, shit again.
And I'll stab you.
two all right now i leave that's what you get for not be
accessible that's right that's for discrimination they in
fact could shoot me from there
bye cool guys don't look cool guys look at explosion and it
looks like all that energy that was sucking up has nowhere
to go Now what is he gonna do now?
That's right.
I did it for all!
Handicapped people!
I did it for you!
That's what you get for not being wheelchair accessible!
That's what they get!
That's right!
I did it for the people!
for something built to fail a victory for wheel kind on the
people's champion
hell yeah that's right discriminate this you're welcome
you're welcome everybody you're welcome imagine all the
people you killed there yeah all the people that could walk
no wheelchair access perish
that's right rise up rise up wheel kind you must be the
handler i presume for the independent mercenary there's no
way any the crew could way there were any crew members that
had wheels on there.
It was not accessible.
You want to join Operation Wall Climber.
You do realize that disposing of some liberation from the
draw did they rise up.
Wheels up!
The wheels up.
I'm proud.
Sit proud.
Are you suggesting your dog can take Freud's place?
That's right.
Bow.
Wow.
My little wheelies will run over your feet.
Who's been equally brazen of late?
Let's see how they both perform.
Perform great, I bet.
Roll out.
Don't keep advocates disabled by making everybody disabled.
And more for us.
Then they'll understand.
You know?
Then they know what we go through.
I'm for the wheels.
I am thrilled to have issued you the request.
Exactly.
True equality right here.
I'm fighting for equal rights.
At your service.
I think I'll enjoy doing business with you.
Yay!
See, he enjoys doing business with me.
I'm doing something right.
You're all just jealous.
He said I'm doing something right, guys.
And I believe.
Alright, Operation Wall Climber.
Assist the assault on the Rubicon, Liberation Front
Stronger, destroy the Juggernaut Heavy.
Mid-okay, friendly craft.
He cannot shoot our legs off in Kali quality.
Bet?
You want to test me?
I've done worse.
You think that's the worst I've done.
It's that should be the least of you concerned.
You will be attacking the wall.
The wall.
of artillery and mt squads break through the line then make
your way to the top of the wall the one there you shall find
the juggernaut a mobile heavy artillery platform destroy it
V4 will also be participating in this mission infiltrating
through a separate route however be aware that Baylam has
also taken a crack at the wall only for their vain glorious
hopes to be dashed do not try not to die like a dog out
there all right don't worry i'll run over his feet with my
wheelchair i got lots of experience objective is to take the
liberation front fortress this is why we don't have any legs
show them your worth of credits six two one
all right here we go
I got meet up with my friend I'll start by clearing the way
for Archibus Take out the Gatling cannons protecting the
city Oh shit I forgot about these guys Oh fuck what cover
I'm in the open field
Take cover, I say, and he says as I start running in the
open air.
All right, now I'll take cover.
All right, let's get rid of these guys real fast.
Oh, shit, it's fine.
I don't, I don't, I'm not here to fight for money right now.
There we go.
Ah, shit.
Not these guys.
You guys are annoying.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's it.
Oh, what?
Bumble God?
What happened to Bumble?
Where did my bubble go?
Oh shit, whoops.
Oh, that's what happened to my bubble.
Never mind, I get it.
Bubble where?
Just grab this guy real quick.
Access the bulkhead and break into the wall.
Oh, it's over here.
I almost got it.
First try.
I was so confident about my bumpers.
All right, close quarter combat.
The closer for my nukes.
Boom!
So close.
Technically, it's close.
Booms are as close as you can get.
I'll have to step up my own game.
Numbered Vespere, he's an elite.
But remember, even Balaam couldn't crack the wall.
Don't count on him too much.
Oh, is Rusty back?
Welcome back, Rusty.
I'm not going to betray you this time.
Alright, there you go.
Oh, we go this way.
Anything is close quarters with big boom!
That's right, you won't shoot a man in a wheelchair.
That's fucked up, bro.
Alright.
Our best friends.
Forever and ever.
Nothing bad's gonna happen to our friendship.
We're not gonna be fighting over a woman.
I'll never do that to you, bro.
Know what they say, bros, before hoes.
621.
all right make sure you resupply oh nice okay where is it oh
it's over here i gotta make sure i actually do resupply rose
before hose guys all right where is it
what are your favorite weapons oh you'll find out
It's hard to tell, guys.
It's very hard to tell which one's my favorite weapon.
Oh, hey.
It's the homie.
I'll never hurt.
I'll never hurt you, bro.
I'll never leave you.
Wow!
I forgot how fucking fast he is.
How are you distracting him?
He fucking came to me first.
Oh, I don't think that was the blind spot.
Let me hit the big, scary armor first.
Guys, I'm helping.
I'm very helpful.
He's off!
Oh wait, it's the one that's not covered by the big armor.
Oh,
you did it?
Get back in here.
If I don't intercept them, we're both toast.
He's gonna fucking shoot him.
But you'll have to finish without me.
Alright.
I'll just stand here.
Oh shit, maybe I shouldn't have stood there.
Guys, don't worry.
Let me stand in the fire.
Fire, good.
Nice.
Confirmed.
Juggernaut destroyed.
Operation Wall Climber is a success.
I don't know where's the not giant solid metal plate It
won't matter I've taken that contingency into account Yeah
Oh he just the bro just left before I finish drop bro hat
bro Bro you're supposed to sticker stay there See your bro
do a cool finishing move I can't believe it Bro left You
didn't believe in me Agent, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Big boom is back.
Seriously, I'm happy to see you go for other endings.
I was worried you'd just end your adventure with this game
with one playthrough.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I know it's a very rare moment.
I've never done new game play before on stream.
The very...
Oh, it's the fur.
No, yeah.
I've never done it before.
So you got the rare dokey moment for free.
I've never done it before for free.
You took the wall.
both the higher ups and the rubiconians are going to
remember the name raven now yippee i'm famous one by one
everybody one by one there's nookie for everyone all right
escort the rubicon liberation front deployed on a prisoner
rescue infiltrate and determine why it went silent i'm gonna
do number two because it has to do with fighting.
Oh,
cool.
I helped him last time.
So long.
That's me.
That's right.
I'm more than that.
I'm a mercenary, too.
I do stuff for money.
I like money.
It's like if you give Mr. Krabs a mecca.
Okay.
Zyko, they give me the gifts and ships.
Thank you, thank you.
And I'm a war criminal.
But it's okay.
I did it for money.
So it cancels out.
It's being war criminal that bad, guys.
Is it really that bad when I'm a rich war criminal?
Don't worry, I'll help you.
How much am I getting paid for it, though?
I'll help you, bro.
All right.
Can you do 50-50 deposit first, you know, because you're a
new client?
In-game.
It was an in-game.
In-game, guys.
All right.
Here we go.
Some advice before you go, 6-2-1.
Expect the unexpected.
all right
it's okay at the canadian pass it's expected of me at this
point it'd be weird if i don't commit war crimes investigate
bouse arsenal number two it'd be weird oh it's this i
remember this wait never mind i remember this there'd be a
canadian that's not committing war crimes that's pretty
suspicious oh my god get that checked up Can't remember.
I just went to the side.
Oh, shit.
Never mind.
I got to go to the side.
A little too quiet here.
Alright.
Watch out.
6-2-1.
From where?
Oh, from there.
6-2-1.
Watch its shots and see where they're coming from.
Do I need to?
Oh, it's this.
Did I hit him?
There we go.
That should have hit him.
Oh, that didn't?
Ah, shit.
Oh, okay, there you go.
Oh, it's the invisible mechs again.
That's okay, I have so much ammo.
I forgot the scan button either.
Guys, guys, I don't know which button is the scan button.
We're gonna go by eyesight alone.
Is it V?
Alright.
It was V.
Oh, shit, it did.
Oh, yeah.
Got you in my sight, too.
Oh, shit, he lives.
621.
there's more than one this time use your scanner mark your
targets to undermine their tricks yeah oh what the fuck why
are you here why are you on the ground keep going stay sharp
yeah let's just go full heal now
oh wait is the fast guy after this Oh, there she is.
Oh, peekaboo!
Oh, shit!
Oh, the combo!
Get out of here!
Okay, that's illegal!
Oh my god, I literally got that.
I got mafia right there.
All right, there should be a resupply soon.
I remember if I remember correctly.
Come on, open up.
I have clearance.
Cool response.
6-2-1.
Get down and take a closer look.
All right.
Oh, I remember.
Oh, no.
Oh, I knew I knew it.
I felt the PTSD.
I was like, why do I feel PTSD right now?
Why do I have a bad feeling about this place?
Oh, welcome back.
Oh, shit.
I don't know where she comes from.
Oh,
my gosh, she was above me.
Oh, my God.
Oh, fuck you.
All right.
Oh, this is so not fair.
There you go.
Oh.
Oh my god!
Why did he jump through all of it?
Another dealt with.
Stay focused, 621.
You bitch.
There we go.
Oh, where is it?
Oh my god, there he is.
I think he's like right there.
All right.
Just in case, just in case, just in case.
Oh, you fucker.
Seems that's the last of them.
This wasn't a simple check-in after all.
Head back and rest up, 621.
Oh, I thought it...
Okay, okay, I thought it was the boss lady.
The really fast bubble bitch.
I thought it was her.
This is not as bad.
Not the one I thought of.
That's good.
Thank God.
I legit thought it was the bubble bitch.
because it was the same arena I had I had that PTSD how's
an arena fight that I have so much trauma on it I didn't
even realize it was an arena I thought it was real life it
felt so real it didn't feel like a simulation all
right what's next one oh this one's new apparently you guys
said this is a new mission i haven't done before i got a job
for you six two one i got another job for me from the
rubicon liberation front raven there's the mission i'd like
you to take on all right we have authorized a solo
helicopter sortie to rescue a group of imprisoned comrades
not too bad i just shoot it down right be okay in the
helicopter.
Don't worry, I'll make sure to shoot down that helicopter
with the prisoners inside.
Alright.
Corolla by Rubicon.
Escort the deployed.
Oh.
Oh, I have to escort them.
I mean not shoot?
I don't understand that word.
You want me to not shoot down a helicopter.
Are you sure the not part was supposed to be in that
sentence?
all right
are you sure i think you might have there's typo in your
mission
you mean no big boons are you is it opposite day today
must have been a typo i think they actually meant for me to
shoot the helicopters i'm pretty sure your man's mission
escort the rubicon liberation Yeah.
See, it's fine.
I was stress testing the helicopter.
We have to rescue our captured comrades.
Failure is not an option.
But what if it...
But what if?
You don't know if it is or is not an option.
What if it became an option?
Alright, let's get this guy out of here.
Oh, wait.
Oh, there is a helicopter!
Yippee!
Yay!
Thank God.
I knew there was a helicopter.
Oh, my God.
Look at all these big helicopters for me.
Okay.
me?
Oh my god, hurry up.
Holy shit.
Do not take this log.
I can just sit on top of here.
Oh my god, it's like my little my little carry.
It is pretty slow.
Shoot from here.
them yeah whoops oh shit wait what's that over there wait i
just have to move up oh wait wait there we go i got them
before they showed up
oh what's that shooting him i was gonna say how am i taking
damage right now mega thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you and happy birthday oh shit give me a second let me
commit some war crime real quick don't let them go don't
worry it'll be really fast i'm canadian all right nice all
right we're good what we're not good all right we're good
happy birthday mega thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you hey dokey it's my birthday today can get you to
sing happy birthday of course
you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear mega happy
birthday to you yeah give me a sec gotta oh my god okay
that's like a fucking gallon gun happy birthday anymore oh
it's all the way there
Bro, I'm trying!
I'm giving it all I got, captain!
Bro, okay, come on.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, maybe don't just walk into them.
Maybe.
Maybe just don't walk in front of all of these guys.
My shoulder ammunition at 30%.
Try hard.
We're okay.
We're so safe.
Guys, it's okay.
Don't worry about the fire on the helicopter.
It's cosmetic.
It's just cosmetic, guys.
It's like we add flames onto the decal to go faster.
And so the helicopter would go faster.
It's been extracted.
Thank goodness you're safe, father.
Or I'll abide with Rubicon.
Wait, there's more?
you don't know what you're saying oh wait that's bad
who mission accomplished six to one new enemy confirmed wait
new enemy who's shooting this tiny little mister oh shit oh
this is bad oh this oh this is bad
Oh, this might be that.
I'm trying.
There's a guy here.
Oh, he's dead.
Oh, he's so dead.
No!
Um, guys, I think I did it, guys.
I think I did it.
Everybody's dead, so that's a win for me.
That's...
No!
But they're all dead!
They're all dead!
If they're all dead, it should be a win.
He took the money.
Okay, I didn't...
Okay, I'm just gonna move all the way forward at this point.
Like...
Okay, I'm just gonna...
I'm not even gonna wait.
I'm not even gonna wait for them.
Try to remember exactly.
where everybody shows up okay it's show up around here I
believe it's very slowly just flying over thank God okay
there we go they're all dead now
All right.
That's everybody.
No, there's more over there.
And now I know.
Sorry,
I took a stroll downtown apparently.
A little rest and I'll pay him back.
side raven he was covered yeah try to remember where the
other ones are i know like more oh there they are oh i
missed there we go ah shit where's the other objective i
don't remember where he goes next
Extracting Conrad Messer.
Oh, there it is.
What the fuck?
He hid behind the building?
He can do that?
Oh, shit.
He can do that.
He hid behind the building.
He fucking cheated.
We've extracted Conrad Messer.
But we were too late.
Damn it.
Not Messer.
is this way oh my god are these guys okay I gotta get there
fine they're shooting at me oh it's no longer fine oh shit
fucking god don't okay it's fine it's fine it's okay wait
sorry my food was here all right I have to stop there
because my food arrived oh my god these guys again too
oh my god i'm trying to try to shoot him 50 percent two
repair kids remaining oh excellent healed and i'm gonna heal
okay we're here now We're at site C.
Extracting Comrade.
Father, don't buy him.
Oh!
But a younger ammunition act.
30%.
Does anyone come up?
Does anyone show up?
All right, we have a little bit more HP now.
Just a little bit more.
It's the little things.
Okay.
Let's grab the...
Thank goodness you're safe, Father.
God.
All right, this is where I have to worry a little.
I can't heal my ship, apparently.
My ship doesn't heal.
Okay, here they come.
All right, this mission fucking sucks.
Let's say thank you.
It's Camel.
I'm surprised you even saw my mech.
It's Camouflage.
You know?
I'm so surprised you saw it.
Escorting a prison break all alone.
You're daring.
I'll give you that.
I'm right, I am.
Oh my god, where is he?
Where is he?
What the fuck?
Wait, I actually need to blow these guys up before I blow
him up.
Why, this is not fair!
Here we go.
Now it's fair.
Now it's fair!
Alright, there we go.
There we go.
We did it!
The power of the wheelchair.
That's right.
We're gonna make this place wheelchair accessible.
It's hard.
First try.
Yeah, yippee.
We saved the prisoners.
We're here.
And then we'll capture them again.
And then get paid by the enemy team.
And then the resistance will pay me to save them again.
And I'll offer my services to the guards.
And I'll catch them again.
And I did an unlimited money glitch.
That's how you do it.
shit in this.
We did it, everybody.
We're a hero.
We're the weapons manufacturer.
That's me.
What happened to 617 in the rest?
Um, they're not.
They did what it took to get us here.
The city is saved to Patrick.
The stability power.
Let's go!
Saber, thank you for the chat thank you thank you five
wheels out of five wheels welcome thank you thank you thank
you hey carla welcome back i'm gonna kill you next there's
something promising in the watch point don't worry carla
i'll let you live for a little longer hey she made me kill
my wife it's karma haha get it
Waiting for my wife to come back.
Kill wife, regret.
That's me.
We couldn't have rescued our comrades.
I'm Raven.
I'm a warrior.
Father Dolmayan is a key figure to the movement.
A great coral warrior who witnessed the fires of Ibis.
My food's here.
I'm going to grab my food.
Now it seems like he's...
No, I shouldn't.
He carries the heavier burden.
than any of us.
He was a prisoner, a POW.
I feel like being a POW might not be great.
I don't know, though.
I don't know, guys.
I feel like being a POW might be a little traumatic.
This request doesn't come from the corpse or the liberation
front.
Yeah?
Where does it come from?
I have other jobs?
Alright.
All right, let me grab my food real quick, guys.
I'm back.
You think breaking my legs will stop me from being full?
You only made me more powerful.
Exactly.
Same.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I got on Geary.
Same.
Oh, oh, oh.
And then a Tamago.
My Tamago.
And an H7.
sandwich and a onigiri and pudding guys I'm prepped guys I'm
already prepping for tomorrow
I'm prepping for tomorrow guys I'm getting my confini food
in
for tomorrow's Capcom quiz how much I know Japan
Gordon thank you a super chat thingy thank you it's got me
thinking why didn't Charles Xavier attach rocket launchers
on Taylor to his wheelchair is he stupid because he has the
Holocaust rave he doesn't need that he can literally beam
the Holocaust into your mind that's stronger than any big
booms
True story.
I'm not joking.
I'm not.
I wish I was.
I wish it was a joke.
Oh, yeah.
They retconned.
Didn't don't have to retcon it now.
Now that like.
It's Magneto.
is like that's the weird part because like it's like the
simpson where abraham simpson um like grandpa was in the
which war was he was supposed to be in world war two and
they have to kept they keep recording him in what war he was
in because this show is still going on he's like i remember
my war days and originally was world war two and now it's in
it's a it's in vietnam now now he's Vietnam War.
And eventually, if the Simpsons is still going, it might be
a different war, too.
They just got in the comments, they just killed him.
And it revived him younger.
That's crazy.
It wasn't Skinner to Vietnam War.
They wrecked on Skinner so much, because they fucked up by
making Skinner, like, not, um, not the, well, not his mom's
child.
um and now they reconned how he was like his her fake son
and they reconned that and made him like her actual son now
but now he's her he's her real son it's like that episode
never happened yeah it got recon so now the episode
technically never happened because they do episodes where he
was Like, he's, like, growing up with Agnes.
Well, it's not that they can't write for shit.
It's that the show has been on for so long.
And a lot of their episodes are connected to real-life
events.
So it's, like, what can they do?
You know?
Like, what the fuck can they do?
It's connected to Sumi.
People get older.
They need to wreck on it.
Oh my god.
Did you hear?
Sorry, I'm having a little food break before we keep going.
Did you hear the reason why smiling friends, the creators
who smiled at friends, stopped making new episodes?
It's because they apparently had a really shitty budget or
something.
The creators revealed why they canceled the show.
Because they got renewed for two seasons.
And it just revealed is because adult swim did not give them
a bigger budget and the budget was just too small that like
they had to do everything by themselves most like most of
the time they had to do a lot of stuff by themselves so they
just decided to cancel it yeah they were doing well but
adult swim just wasn't giving them enough money to like keep
the keep the quality going yeah
so these were like We're just gonna cancel it It just didn't
think that you're gonna get more money Which is crazy
Because Smile Friends was doing so well
Maybe Rick and Morty took up all the budget I think like
Smile Friends was like Um It was like a good successor Like
a good Like I guess like a co-pillar With Rick and Morty
Um But also, Warner Bros.
as a company is pretty ass, though, so.
So, like, I won't be surprised if they're just giving small
budgets to animated shows.
Oh, yeah.
I read the Wally Coyote movie, got 100% Rotten Tomatoes.
I don't know if it's just, um, it's just like people just
reviewing it good just for the sake to stick it to the man,
or if it's actually good.
I hope it's good.
I actually really liked, um, which of the ones?
the one with uh with Fraser Brandon Fraser this is the one
with Brandon Fraser with Looney Tunes uh where he did the
Looney Tunes adventure what movie was that that one I
actually really like that movie
was it Brandon Fraser which was it that back in action I
actually really enjoyed back in action I rewatched that
movie like three times when I was growing up I was growing
up The trailer reminded me of that.
So I hope the movie, I hope Wally Coyote.
The Wally Coyote movie is good.
Because it had like a 100% rotten tomatoes.
I don't, like I said, I don't know if it's just critics
trying to stick it to the man.
Or if it's actually a good movie.
All right, let me wash my hands.
And then we'll keep playing.
We're back.
all right let's go i'm ready let me get to see my pudding
yet but i don't want to get spoon i'm lazy at the moment i'm
looking forward to wait is there spoon in here my pudding
pudding no they don't have a spoon oh i have a spoon in here
jk that was bait Let me eat my pudding first.
I'm so sad because Hong Kong right now has a Pom Pom Paren
collaboration.
Um, with a...
I'm an Onigiri chain right now.
And it looks so cute.
I actually saved it.
I'll show you guys what it looks like.
That's it.
I saved it in my bookmarks.
Give me a sec.
Ha ha.
a sec.
I'm an adult, by the way.
Hey, where is it?
Did I not save it?
No, I did.
Give me a sec.
There you go.
I'm above 18, guys.
I wouldn't want to try it there.
Cheesecake custard.
Is that cheesecake custard?
The asshole.
Sorry, out of context.
But you know what I'm talking about.
That slut showing his booty hole like that.
That's how he buys his boots.
That horror.
Alright.
Attack watchpoint.
Eliminate SG squad at watchpoint.
Destroy the device.
That sounds easy.
of don't call him that this is a rather personal request
then maybe stop showing his asshole to everyone huh
he doesn't deserve rank one in the sandrido polls i want you
to attack it he didn't earn it cinnamaro never showed off
here his asshole The watchpoint is kept secure by SG.
He didn't need it to rank one.
Which means it's too hard for corporations to be seen there.
In other words, we're flying strictly solo on this one.
Yeah, I didn't remember that laser damage.
Yeah, he didn't have to degrade himself for rank one.
Let him express himself.
You'll be going in under control of darkness.
He's just playing Metatoki.
Be ready for anything.
Alright.
I'm ready.
I'm ready for anything.
Like he said.
It's go time, 621.
I'm gonna get fucking destroyed by the lasers.
You guys are gonna be like, be careful lasers.
I want lasers.
I would anticipate a solo, independent mercenary.
Get in there.
I don't even know how far I am into the first ending Is
there already been two sorry been two okay to be fair so
we've been an hour
Do you think they saw me
Do not let anyone see you Don't worry guys Nobody saw me.
I'm pretty sure.
If you're seen contained, the situation.
Situation contained.
Two repair kits remaining.
Oh, the other one's over here.
Oh, yeah.
I was supposed to go on the left.
I went on the right.
whoops got my left and right's mixed up oopsie t-he where is
it oh there it is unaware thank god code seven eight
requesting backup i can't get through the hq the cavalry
isn't coming Wipe them out, 6-2-1.
Oh, nice.
Okay, now I can steal all of them.
That's easy enough.
Yay!
Nobody's gonna run over you.
Yippee!
You're never gonna see your daughter grow up and get
married.
Your wife's gonna be a widow now.
Ha-ha.
Alright, last guy's all the way there.
Nobody's gonna save you.
Your wife is pregnant and you'll never see the birth of your
child.
Haha.
Nero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm a fire of my laser.
Hey, they shot first.
They could have ran away.
They chose to fight me.
So in the end, they deserve to die.
Confirmed enemy squad destroyed move on to the next area All
right, next area tab Where did that AC come from what
happened to the patrol this one is loot.
This is the cabin Okay, not you not you
Maybe they shouldn't take that oh my god How did he know?
I was so stealthful.
How the fuck did he know?
Oh, it's this one.
It's the two bosses.
There's one over here.
This guy.
Wheelchair on.
Wheelchair time.
That wasn't where I was.
you're incorrigible handler walter oh you're the one with
legs sorry the other guy how many of your dogs must i kill
before you learn maybe it's time for you to learn
oh my god i forgot it's bubble time oh my god oh wait i
remember you no i remember you all right you gotta come play
here on my On my turf, though.
Oh, my god.
Are you serious?
Oh, shit.
It's fine.
The closer you are, the better it is for me.
Oh, shit.
You're close to me.
Get close to me.
The closer you are!
The better it is!
And you know it!
There you go.
Yeah, he kicked me in a wheelchair.
Wait, wait a minute.
I don't need a POW bunker on you.
That's right, you're not important enough.
No problem.
That's right, you don't even get the POW bunker.
Alright, here we go.
Come on, let me in.
Let me in.
Yeah, weaklings don't deserve the POW.
Exactly.
You're too weak for my real weapon.
Free supply.
Bro, that guy tried to kick a man in a wheelchair.
Someone cancel him right now.
Wee.
Destroy the device in the center.
Okay.
I think I did it.
And then I slowly go back up.
Where do I watch it?
Good job, 61.
Yeah!
That's me.
Good soldiers follow orders.
Wifey time!
I love her so much and I'll never ever kill her.
It took me like 45 minutes.
Oh, hey, Banda.
Literally, it took me 45 minutes to be like we just streamed
it.
Don't worry.
I got you.
It's going to take me 44 minutes.
Yippee!
I will never, ever, ever kill you.
at all, my beautiful wife.
Slay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do you read or have fun reading?
I found this light novel series that talks about mechas.
And the author is a big armor core fan.
I used to read a lot.
It depends on the book.
Before your consciousness.
Never will I ever blow you up with my big booms.
And I'm not talking about the ones in bed.
God, I'm so smooth.
You know, when our big booms touch?
In front of that.
I'm putting all my cards on the table.
confident oh shit wait that guy oh shit I think I was lucky
when I beat him I was immensely lucky I don't even know if I
could replicate it anymore we lost all of it
We lost the data.
No!
Boom!
Okay.
Oh my god.
My wheelchair!
Why are you flying?
I'm on a wheelchair!
This is not wheelchair accessible.
Okay.
Holy shit!
I would like to inform you that he is not wheelchair
accessible.
Where am I?
Yeah!
That's how you do it.
it.
That was just for content.
Easy.
That's that, yeah.
First try.
Wheelchair prevails yet again.
Don't worry.
This is for Bandai.
Make more ramps.
in your facility.
But first a warning.
What, like he's art or something?
The coral surge you were swept up in.
That was just a glimpse.
Bandai and wheelchair lovers all around.
Sit proudly.
Wheels on.
Wheels up.
That's right.
You know what I said?
It was luck that I beat him the first time.
It wasn't luck.
All skill.
A friend of mine sent me this observational data.
Look, 621.
You get a rap.
And you get a rap.
Wheels up.
It's headed straight for the central ice field.
Across the Aalian ocean.
Like a flock of birds or a school of fish.
time to do a wheelie on that sick coral with my wife you
said you could hear a strange voice in your head that's a
common side effect of old gen augmentation could also be
from getting caught in that coral surge you know the
benefits of being on a on a wheelchair with a hot wife If
she gets tired, she can just sit on my lap and I can just
wheel her at any way she wants.
That's right, walkers.
Can you do that?
And even yet, compared to the fires of Ibis, that explosion
was hardly a spark.
Raven, I have a favor to ask.
Let me remain in contact with you until we reach the Coral
Convergence.
No.
See?
Bandai gets it.
That's right, my queen.
Don't tire your feet.
Sit here.
Wait.
My queen.
A queen shouldn't walk.
Augmented human.
C4621.
Entering standard mode.
Two new messages.
621.
I've got some business to attend to.
I need to hawk some intel to the corpse and secure a backer
for our trip to the ice field.
One shop for you while I'm out.
How is that camel hurting your eyes?
You can't see it.
That's an order.
LARPer?
It's like I'm in this.
What is the book?
I see your handlers away on business for now.
Yeah, he's gone.
Oh yeah, he is gone.
What do you want to do?
I got a trip to the ice field.
We've received a job from Balaam already.
Let's take a look, shall we?
Yeah, let's take a look in this room by ourselves.
There's no supervision.
What?
Yeah!
Which brings us to a request.
Yeah?
What do you want?
Integration program?
This program concerns Mind Alpha, a pilotless AC that we
have developed.
Sampling the various factions, machines, to assimilate their
technology and design philosophies.
We would like you to engage it in arena combat.
Oh shit!
A new...
Assist us with the future of armor technology.
Oh my god, new mecha to fight in the arena?
at it.
Wait, what's this?
Oh.
Wait, I never finished this.
Oops, I didn't even realize.
Oh, nice.
Free money.
Intent mercy arrived on Rubicon around the time the Coral
response was rediscovered.
Held to be a man bear of the branch, a hacktivist,
collective, active in the Rubicon.
King is said to have co-founded an entire fleet of heavy
warships and a solo diversionary maneuver during the attack
on station 31 I did not realize that there were more yeah
free money number three only the best remain that's right
it's me subject AC astro crown call sign King all right King
always gets dethroned.
Long live the king.
The fuck just tanked it.
Stupid.
Are you a...
Are you stupid?
Got a king, aren't you?
Just tank it?
Just like that?
Oh, shit!
I guess me too!
Same z's!
Oh my god, a Get close to you because you're just flying
Boom!
Oh shit.
Okay, that's bad for me.
Oh shit, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Nice.
That JK.
There we go.
That's fucking right.
Not even close!
Too easy.
That's right.
I'm gonna add wheels to that throne.
I swung for the head.
Alright, now it's free money.
Me like free stuff.
Do I even need anything, to be fair?
I feel like I've upgraded a lot of stuff.
Uh, I got the explosive.
The melee.
What do I even need anymore?
Hacking.
Dynamic deflection.
Maybe this?
Damage mitigation?
Right?
Direct hit.
Modify.
Oh, I didn't see that.
Uh, against...
Oh, yeah, I need that, actually.
Forgot about that one.
Wait, I get more armor?
Unlocks.
So I'm not...
Oh, wait, no.
I don't need that because I have pulse armor.
Uh...
Alright.
More free stuff.
Let's go.
Commander the Red Guns, the Bound Group's AC Squad.
Michigan took up the leadership after career as the
commander of the Forlong Armed Thief.
There he earned a reputation as a merciless heavy-handed
ogre of a man.
He was equally feared by friend and foe alike, who knew him
as hell on four legs.
Apparently he has posted bounty on his own head.
Oh, cool.
He wants a challenge!
Alright.
The combat aptitude evaluation program.
Let's go.
Number two, rank S.
Break two.
How good are you really though?
Oh, he's not going straight in.
Oh shit, wait, you have your own missile?
But yeah, it's bigger than mine though.
your missile, huh?
Oh, shit.
Where did he go?
Guys, this missile's pretty big.
Oh, my God.
It might have been bigger than I thought.
We compared missile size, and it did not go well for me.
We compared missile size.
All right, all right, let's try this again.
He's racing circles around you.
And finally, a boom to match my booms.
This will be a battle of the century.
Oh, my God.
Where did he go?
It's not fair.
He's in the air when I stun him and then he shoots me with a
gun.
No, no commitment.
No commitment.
I did a big boom life.
Finally a worthy opponent.
He doesn't commit.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
That's it.
It's not fair.
He's actually...
cheating if you think about it he's actually hacking where
did he go
get down from here i'm on a wheelchair okay there i mean i
did it he got down one way or another stands at the apex of
the arena
Yeah, he got it down.
There we go.
Easy.
It's so easy.
He stopped eventually.
All right.
Last one.
Void.
Rank one.
Commander of the Vesper.
The Aquabus Group's augmented human.
human squad.
Nace pilot would achieve an astonishing 94.7 mission to
success rate.
That's right, we're going to lower that one.
Forward is widely suspected to be the recipient of the
repeated adjustment, much like Chanel.
Out of the real void is simply an ordinary human being, a
man who enjoys piloting his ADC and making a way.
I feel like I fought this guy before.
I remember reading that description.
This will be the last evaluation.
Subject AC.
Oh shit, that's a hardcore emblem.
Just a regular guy, apparently.
Yeah, I remember killing him.
Yeah, I fought him in the first inning.
I was like, I remember killing you.
Oh my god.
Don't punch you.
Here you go.
I don't know, did I hit him?
I...
Oh my god, you fought.
I didn't do this again.
I didn't do this.
Oh, yeah, you're rank one.
You're rank one.
Rank two was hiding.
Get out of here.
You're rank one.
That's right.
He's a fraud.
Freud?
More like fraud.
That's fucking right.
This concludes all evaluations.
We thank you for your cooperation.
the rank one?
Who boosted you?
Who played in your Mecca?
Rank, rank.
That's right.
I'll call the riot devs on you.
Get your rank reset for being boosted.
Yeah.
Stop.
He's already gone.
All ranks.
Though these encounters may be simulated, I was like,
who's...
Who boosted this Discord kid in?
Were you to aid us in our research and development?
All mind exists for all mercenaries.
Yeah, I completed it.
Okay, let's grab some upgrades then.
Before we do the other stuff.
What do I want to do?
This one, right?
And then I have four more.
Terminal armored What do we want to do guys?
Which would be good for us?
Damage reduction?
Is it dynamic deflection control?
It's that one, right?
Is this one?
Damage mitigation, right?
Alright, I just want to be sure.
Alright, analysis.
of its mercenary support initiative all my conduct zone
research all right we're gonna improve the AI it's machine
learning we're gonna improve the AI
okay and then she's gonna take our jobs after now I'm gonna
get fired and then the the ai i the ai i trade is just gonna
take my job just like real life fucker you oh my god you
fucker
no he's already learned
He's already gonna take my job!
No!
He doesn't even have to wait.
He's already doing it.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
Wow, that was a huge gas.
I didn't- I thought I still had time!
Before he take my job!
Bro, I'm too fast!
Why is he so far?
Oh my god.
No!
Wait, we both died!
That should be a success!
No, it can't be a ported!
He's dead!
No, this should be a draw!
Okay The draw Oh
my god, oh my god
Okay, there we go there we go I just had to get close Oh,
I'm sometimes I'm just too fast Concluding analysis well
done All right easy.
So easy.
Wasn't even worried, guys.
Wasn't worried at all.
Okay, I can get more damage mitigation though, at least.
Alright, round two.
Ooh, eight now.
I mean, they're all the same thing.
It just says the same thing.
It really is.
How bunker is the solution to all problems.
Integration program.
Alpha 2.
The next sample is the trainer AC.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
Where is he though?
Is he on top of this hill?
Oh!
He was.
Okay, that's cheating.
You're in the air.
am i supposed to do
okay buddy i ain't your buddy pal
oh my god i'm trying to shoot my gun oh my god that's
awkward for me okay wait he has like no fucking just like no
firearm power actually he's just very he's just like a
little fly
It's like he wants to die.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, he could shoot back?
There we go.
He is a little fly.
Target destroyed.
Including analysis.
Pro is trying his best.
Alright.
nice look and he's little though he might be a little fly
but he's still little
it's dodging my swats you try hitting a flower fly swatter
it's not as easy as you think it is okay next one
but what if he was a thousand flies yeah while he's flying
try to hit fly with a fly swatter while he's flying
integration program face not when he's fucking sitting down
and rubbing his goddamn hands and throwing up on your food
the next sample is the tester ac this will be integrated
into mind alpha commencing analysis all right last analysis
Oh my god, why can't...
Bro, why can't all these AC be just like you?
Why can't they just all walk in the straight line for me?
Oh my gosh, wait, I'll just tank it.
What am I doing?
What?
Damn!
He can just do that!
Oh my god.
There we go.
So where did he go?
Wait, where did he go?
There we go.
Bro hit all truck instincts.
What a fucking dodge from this AI.
The data will be integrated into Mind Alpha.
Thank you for your assistance.
See, I told you.
There we go.
all right nice eight more dollars for me i'll take those
i'll take my eight dollar runies incoming calls
thank you for your continued support you're welcome testing
has identified several key points for improvement to mind
alpha the evolution of all mind will not disappoint all
right
If I have enough, no, I need two more dollars.
All right, let's go in.
Infiltrate Grid 86 and reach the center.
Okay, that's easy.
Speed run time.
Round two, Electric Boogaloo.
They want you to carry out an advanced survey of the central
ice field.
All right, sounds easy enough.
To confirm the information Walter brought to them about the
coral convergence.
As for how to cross the Aalien Ocean.
This is the intercontinental cargo launcher installed on the
upper level of Grid 086.
You could use it to launch your AC to the ice field.
Grid 086 is occupied by the dozers, outlaws who treat coral
like a drug.
It's also the territory of a belligerent group of...
If it's bad, why does it taste so good?
ID.
Be prepared for a parent's journey.
I'll be here to support you, Raven.
Infantry grid.
Reach center.
I got this.
Let me handle getting us into the grid.
They're just trying to gatekeep it.
They don't know shit.
They're just trying to gatekeep.
What's right?
maybe like dosing is like the next step of human evolution
we need more data to decide guys you got they got a dose
more to decide if to figure out if it is connecting steam
cylinders
yay we
I'm back here.
You wouldn't puff your wife, would ya?
Alright.
Well, I don't have to actually fight them.
I just gotta get over there.
Oh shit.
I mean, it's just one little guy.
Well, it's just two little guys.
Three little guys.
Sorry, I miscounted.
Oh, it's you!
Oh, you're the...
Oh, wait, actually, it is bad.
No, never mind.
Maybe wife was right.
I forgot about this guy.
This guy's a little crazy.
I forgot about that, man.
Beat guy.
There we go.
Goodbye, beat man.
Yeah, never mind.
He's a prime example of why drugs are bad.
All right, he'll go.
Oh, it's Carla!
Alright, time to get stomped on by Carla.
What's that?
Oh, shit!
Bad guy!
What's that dropping on me?
Is it a loot box?
Sorry, I thought it was a loot box.
I was like, woo, loot box.
How do I get it?
Oh, it's up here.
All right, down I go.
I go this way.
All right, there we go.
Wait, he's alive?
Whoop.
He was alive.
I'm right.
Oh, up top.
Gamer's looking up.
Gamer's still looking up.
Here I go.
Who shot me?
Oh my god, these tiny little guys shot me?
Get out of here!
Your life is meaningless, and you're only being... You're
only created to be stock fodder for me.
Yeah, exactly.
Loopbox mimics.
Now that's a scary thought.
For him.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ah, no.
Like this thing, games would never do such a horrible thing.
There's a fight back there.
Is it worth it?
How worth it is this fight?
Where is this fight that you speak of?
This one?
These little guys that aren't doing anything?
Oh shit!
These big guys that are?
These big guys that will avenge the little guys?
Huh?
Just because I can.
That's it.
Go back to where the molten is.
Oh, you mean back there in the little hole?
Alright.
Just better be worth my time.
Oh, wait.
Didn't I fight this before?
Okay.
here yeah I got the pipe guy a while ago yeah the guy that's
that needs money yeah I already did it not too bad guys I
already fought killed him yeah I remember he needed money
and I killed him because I needed money more I'm more
desperate for money.
That's right.
I didn't have to kill him, but I did it for hee-ha-ha fun.
I actually did not have to kill them because I don't have a
lot of ammo left.
Oh, shit!
What happened to me?
Oh, shit.
I lost all everything I think somebody threw a bomb I got
crushed
yeah I forgot about the explosive trap I threw a bomb in my
head it's like dropping an anvil I was like yeah watch this
guys all right well now i know there's a bomb so i won't be
doing that no more
all right well now i learned gamers clear gamers still don't
look up
will gamers ever learn time to find out all right All right,
time to get stomped on by Carla.
Maybe that's why he's mad stomped.
That's where he got it from.
That's where he got his awakening.
Oh, yeah, the resupply.
I don't really need to, but I might as well.
All right, here we go.
I'm afraid of beautiful, tall, confident women.
though but who is it it's only natural oh
my god Jesus Christ oh
my god I'm
Okay, I'm just going to do this just in case because I don't
trust myself.
I absolutely do not trust myself.
He's going to aim for this.
I just feel more comfortable.
Oh my god, I guess I don't.
Oh, I can't chop that.
That's it.
I feel so comfortable in the air.
Oh, we're so close, though.
Oh, fuck.
We're almost there.
No.
Slow and steady.
Very slow and steady.
apparently there we go it's alright when I'm in the air
thank God see I know see I know the wheelchair strap I knew
it hit the moment I flew up she couldn't do anything after
that that's right I did a wheelie on her
Nice.
I do look like a whops, not gonna lie.
Mission complete.
That is it.
Thank God.
Thank God I get to keep everything.
Thank fucking God.
This would not have gone well for me if I had to go do this
all over again with nothing.
Hey, tourist.
That's me.
Or that's you.
I had to work some of my magic to track you down.
I've got a little job for you.
Take a
look.
Raven, it's highly unusual to receive messages from hostile
sources.
Did she hack into all mine's mercenary database?
Oh?
Without consent?
That's fucked up.
You're getting cancelled, Carla.
Alright, stop.
a secret data breach destroy all hacking drones installed
all right mission failure of hack is allowed to complete oh
that's easy enough my favorite little tourist about my
promise to take you up top i need a little help cleaning up
first okay you see a certain someone smashed up all my
defense hardware and now i've got rival dozers muscling in
it's the junker kind of We never did get on.
Always sniffing around, just waiting for a chance to bite.
Making a mess is one thing, but they're going after our
development data too.
We need to swap the hacking drones they sent before they
make off with all my secrets.
I mean, that's easy to do.
We've done it before.
Is there how much she loves being a Mecha Merc pilot?
I'm curious how long before she tries to make Warrior 5?
Are this the first CKP?
They give a super chat.
Thank you.
I haven't heard of that game before.
Mom?
Me?
You can make up for it by keeping my secrets safe.
How is it my fault?
I'm just a mercenary.
If anything, it's whoever pays me's fault.
I just do what I'm being told.
Your handler didn't authorize this sortie either.
You know what you're gonna do is snitch on me?
I thought you'd like a bad boy.
If it's so bad, why are you attracted to it, Aria?
You could pick any other Mecca to be in their minds, but you
picked mine.
I thought you liked baddies.
Oh, shit, they're already hacking.
Hello, I'm not even here yet.
Let's be quick about this, Raven.
security breaches reached 10 percent it's not even fair i'm
not even in the area oh my god they're just flying away
they're this is illegal
all right
seems pretty annoying yeah
I see it Oh my god, he's on the other side Like I see you,
but how do I get to you?
Oh here That's how
What the fuck Oh my god, they're like little termites
Coyotes are using RADM2s the black market oh my god i can't
see i can't see oh my god there you are
it's like right here you're not right here oh my god you're
right here
where's the last one though you'd have to try to mess it up
now Oh, it's here.
Security breaches reached 50%.
Wait.
Where?
If you can't smoke the targets, try using your skin.
Oh my god, you're right here.
You're just hiding under there.
Like a little bitch.
Oh, what the fuck?
I was like, who's that over here?
Who's this guy?
Send the coyotes and their pals a little countervirus.
Our servers are officially fried.
Oh my god, that's where you are.
What?
They're outside?
Okay,
I'll do it this way.
I'm just gonna make sure I have...
Oh my god, you little bitch.
How do I go outside?
It's like the blind leading the blind.
There you go.
Oh, it's over here.
Alright.
Outside, tab.
Okay, this is a new mission.
I don't remember this.
I was like, I've done this so many times.
It's gonna be fine.
And I was like, I don't know if I remember this.
Have I done this mission before?
And here I thought I'd just make some extra scratch.
Oh, it's a gauzu.
It's Money Man.
Guess I could settle the score at the same time.
I see the coyotes got some help too.
Don't forget to smile, Taurus.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I was like, don't worry, I've done
this so many times.
I got this.
And I was like, wait, I don't remember this.
I was so confident that I've done this before too.
I don't know.
I was like, yeah, totally done this one.
What the hell?
They're all over us.
Help me out or we're both dead.
All right, fine.
I guess I'll help out.
Fine.
Time out!
Or I shoot you.
Fuck yo, you first though.
Ha ha ha ha.
Yeah, but at least we died again.
Okay, maybe I should kill him first, though.
All right, we got him down.
All right, back to our batch.
Okay, well, he has to kill him first, so I'm gonna wait.
Is he shooting me?
I'll just wait.
He's still fighting them
Oh my god, it's a 1v2 if only he had another mecca to help
them
Oh shit We did it Wait he won
Oh shit, I'm not whoops There we go I don't know about that
that buddy i don't know if you've had me i'll have the crew
check out those mechs get deleted bro get bunkered
oh nikki my lovely wife i know you got this i believe in you
Yeah, it's such a tryhard.
Kill them without even trying.
Just waited.
It's not pussy move, guys.
It's called strats.
It's strategy.
Just mad because you didn't use your brain.
Guess you noticed that job from Balem and decided to take
it.
Next time, look before you leap.
I got extra money for us I like money what do you mean I
have extra money all right next next mission reached
international cargo launcher found deep within the elder
shell area all right time to do that We're continuing
through grid 086, toward the Intercontinental Cargo
Launcher.
As promised, Carla has agreed to serve as our guide.
I'm not sure how safe it is to trust a dozer.
Yeah, after Mad Stop, I don't know.
We turned her knowledge down as well.
That's how she...
Mad Stop got reawakened.
Carla's nickname...
Okay.
That's what the Rubiconians call survivors of the fires of
Ibis But if the fires happened half a century ago Well, it
could just be some dozer inside joke
So you should be fine.
Don't worry my wife Dunked on igazoo.
Yeah He got pow bunker done bunked on.
She enjoys being with me.
She's lowering her expectations with this routine.
I got her.
Yes.
I wielded her down.
She's gonna have to settle now.
Yippee!
I got her to settle!
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's alright, I'll just pay your drugs.
Apparently that works.
This elevator goes straight to the top of the grid.
The outer shell.
Sadly, that's beyond my territory.
I mean, once you're out there.
Yeah?
Do you see a satellite see everything?
Alright.
A few of the stupider dozers took it as a challenge.
Went out to prove themselves.
You can guess what happened.
They lived a happy long life?
They found a wife and had lots of wonderful kids and are now
retiring.
Surely that's what happened, right?
Oh, I remember this area.
Oh, I remember this.
Oh, I absolutely remember this.
Okay, just keep riding.
Just keep riding.
Oh!
Just keep just keep wheeling.
Just keep wheeling.
Don't worry.
I'm on a wheel!
Mono wheelchair.
I'll make it.
Oh,
okay.
All right.
Taking cover.
Oh, that's a little too close for comfort.
It's okay.
I just won't clean up while you're here, tourist.
Never did care for the upstairs neighbors.
Well, I'm here now.
Now you want me to fight back?
Oh shit, okay, it's fine.
What the fuck?
It's no longer fine.
All right, well they killed themselves.
Thank God.
What?
Oh Wow, oh
It's never good when there's a resupply.
Oh, it's here.
Oh Oh, the PTSD is it?
Oh, the PTSD
Not the PTSD Oh, no I Oh my god.
Oh no, not this again.
God, I hope it is.
Okay,
all right.
Okay.
It's okay.
I've learned how to fight you.
I fought harder.
Thank God.
I killed my wife.
I didn't kill you.
No, of course not.
Of course not.
I would have never killed my wife.
I love her so much.
I...
All right, there we go.
I got this.
Fucking easy.
Couldn't even finish her dialogue.
That's how easy.
see it once.
That's not good.
That's your family and relatives.
Look at that.
You couldn't see me because I was camoed.
Past toky would be so proud.
She would be so proud of me that I first tried it just like
how I first tried it last time
oops embrace yourself disconnects
all right here we go
by the way tourist yeah your walters held right um I'm a
independent mech well I guess a dog can't choose its master
but still Look, I feel sorry for you a real what?
What you mean?
I'm a strong independent dog Oh,
and one more thing You know the cargo launchers yeah, for
cargo right?
What about it?
No one's ever used it to launch themselves before at least
not in one piece.
I mean, I didn't well you mean You mean, not a second time?
No one did it a second time.
Yeah, I'm a strong independent contractors.
Whoa.
I'm so cool.
Yeah, my beautiful wife.
That's very much alive and I'll never kill you ever.
You see it too.
Of course, I see your family.
visit your parents what would be very much you're very much
alive parents where nothing bad's gonna happen to them
Walter was correct in his judgment
the coral it's here in this oh it's here's the worm time oh
no wait you have to fight the worm again no not the worm
Ah, not the worm.
Yes, the worm.
Augmented human.
C4-621.
Entering standard mode.
One new message.
Alright, what is it?
Looks like you've made it to the central ice field.
621.
We're definitely speed riding, though, for sure.
I'm done tying up loose ends.
found their own way in and are ready to deploy so many
squads and it looks like balaam's day batusa the guardians
of the galaxy guy got casted as new creatos because the
other creatos fucking snapped his muscle or some shit you
can make it work for us
what's gonna stop him from snapping his muscle yeah the drax
guy the drax guy is replacing the other creatos guy i don't
remember exactly what happened to him.
But, like, I remember, like, it was something to do where if
he like fucked up his arm, or he fucked up his arm, right,
during filming.
And they can't wait for his recovery, so they're recasting
him.
Yeah, but he's extra skinny now, because he stopped taking
steroids.
Was he broke his leg?
I don't remember.
I don't remember because they can't recast.
They can't wait for him to heal, because they're on a very
strict schedule.
attack the survey can of caesar that's easy based on numbers
of enemies i don't even think i need i don't think i need
that bonus he tore his butt yeah that's what i said he
snapped his muscle it's a request from one of the balum
companies attention gun 13 raven this job comes from our
subsidiary dafung the operation will take place in the
centralized fields yalmar mine We want you to stage an
attack on the Archibus Survey camp located there.
After digging into the ice field, Archibus launched
something to get out of there.
The voice actor for Winnie the Pooh was so mad that he
wasn't inducted into the Disney Legends, like the Disney
Hall of Fame.
All right, seizing in the data.
Seize the day.
We're counting on you, Gunther.
They inducted the Rock and Lin-Manuel.
versus what's the name Jim Cummings yeah and he was like he
was sub he was like sub tweeting about Disney which I
thought was really funny like what are they gonna do fire
him that guy literally voice acted like a hundred characters
for Disney yeah like Lin Manuel the Rock the Jonas brothers
all got inducted into the uh the Disney Legends Hall of Fame
and then Jim Cummings the voice of poo um and the others and
the rest was still like over jim yeah oprah's in it and not
jim and then he started sub tweeting about it i think the
funny part is that he started sub tweeting and retweeting
all the fans who were mad about it yeah dark wing duck yeah
the jonas brothers got in instead of him i thought that was
fun no that is Pretty fucked, not gonna lie.
621.
Eliminate obstructions as you see fit.
But remember that the data is your problem.
It's the same data.
I'm just gonna leave.
The Jonas Brothers got it instead of him, which I thought
was pretty funny.
Wow!
Okay, I sort of was Messing around right there There we go,
goodbye
Just guiding it Really, this is how you're going to guard
this
This is how you're going to guard your data With five, like
a dollar store mech
Finally, I'm going up
Oh, I should have invested your tax dollars on better
defenses.
Like, one boom destroys everything.
Oh, you're really dead.
It's fine.
I have this to cover me.
I'm wearing your little pea bullets.
Okay.
Um, Mickey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nominating ordinary actors to legendary voice actor like Jim
Cummings just show how Disney only care about the lame life.
Actually, honestly, true.
Not that you.
The fact that Oprah's in it and not Jim Cummings, like what
has Oprah done for Disney?
I'm actually, I'm actually confused.
What has Oprah done for Disney?
Oh my god, what the fuck he just fucking backed up this car?
There we go.
Get out of here.
Juge, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for the great stream.
Gotta go to bed.
See ya.
I'm Bob.
Thank you for watching.
Juge, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
She was only in a wrinkled and tied.
Bro, what?
That's it?
I legit thought maybe like they did, she did more.
I was so confused.
Shoot that for now.
It's fine.
Bro,
I forgot that movie existed.
It's like you're off with some feathers.
Taking their drones back to HQ.
I want you to find them and stop.
I don't think anybody remembered the existence of that
movie.
I have to go.
Where's my new mission?
Oh, it's over there.
Okay, it's above me.
Mewoo!
Rewon time!
Oh my god, you missed?
I thought I was bad.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
I came over just to stab you.
That makes you extra special.
Oh, yeah, she was in Lion King.
Live action, right?
It's a book and a book only.
Oh, yeah, and Jim Cummings was, like, at D23, too.
Because he was like, I wonder if they'll announce me.
They didn't announce him.
Spoiler alert, they did not announce him.
That's easy.
It's just shooting a chip.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm watching out.
Oh yeah, this guy.
How do I kill this?
Okay, I gotta...
My wheelchair's gotta fly up.
Oh my god, it's the upper limit already.
Never mind.
Give me a sec.
Give me a sec!
Alright, that's it.
I'm fucking staying up here.
Oh my god!
I hate it when they can fly!
That's it.
I'm coming down.
Get out of here.
Where's the last guy?
Get over here!
I'll swat you down like the simulations!
Oh my god.
All right, here we go again.
Bro, hot cow.
That's it.
This is how.
Boom!
That's right.
Smash the bridge.
It's going to blow.
Get clear, 6-2-1.
I'm trying!
No!
I did it I stayed clean battleship down I did it that it I
used I used teleportation instant transmission
looks like the coast is clear
Yeah, that is the transmission.
The closure area is SG's jurisdiction.
Why send an enforcement squad into a warship?
Special mission, maybe.
Or was it?
Wait.
Was it what?
Maybe they should have armor like around the the week.
It's like maybe they should have armor around the weak point
you know not let it hang out hang there all
right looks like we got a little too eager 621 oh no the
cops i can't go back it can't take me back not the popo i
don't have enough bribe money this time i say with eight
million dollars in my bank account Hey, Raven.
It's me, Rusty.
Rusty!
I'll never betray you, my good old buddy, old pal.
I haven't talked since we climbed the wall.
The wall.
I'd love to catch up, but I'll cut to the chase.
The PCA has deployed its suppression fleet.
And now it's laying down the law all over Robicon.
We've already lost several survey bases.
And Balaam's in a sorry state, too.
For their part, the Rubicon Liberation Front sees this as an
opportunity.
If you ask me, they're counting the ranks before they're
hatched.
At this rate, the corpse, the Rubiconists, and the
independent mercs will go down together.
I'm sending you a request from the Archivist Group.
We could use the Wall Climbers' help.
Okay.
I've done this before.
Can't be too bad.
I see you got a call from V4.
I've been contacted as well by the Balaam group.
Seems both sides have been forced to halt the Coral Survey.
Check the briefing, 621.
Raven, I've also picked up a job for you.
corporations who have their eye on you.
The Rubiconians do too.
Go ahead.
Following the PCA's attack, the Rubicon Liberation Front has
established a division in the Central High School.
Yeah, we're on their side now, right?
This job comes from their commander.
Alright.
Now it's a choice.
Guys, which one did I did last time?
This is where it splits up.
right?
Which one comes?
Which one's from the Rubiconian?
Isn't that the split-up sign?
I mean, I could do these first, right?
I did Tunnel Sabotage?
Sabotore.
Alright.
So now I have to start with the Rubiconians.
Yeah.
Now I need to prevent it.
The corporate salvage of new tech.
they pay wait who pays more oh my god why did i do this one
they paid so little
how the did i do that he's barely paid why the fuck did i
because wife oh yeah white oh yeah sorry i'm sorry sweetie i
didn't mean that i forgot that was the wife mission that was
when i choose love over money and i kept choosing love over
money since.
Happy one.
If I pick this, do these two missions say, do I get to do
these two missions or do I just go straight to here?
Or will that bring me to a new area?
Guys.
Because I don't know if I did, did I do these two?
Does it matter if I do these two?
I've always chosen love.
Alright, I guess we do prevent.
We'll just do the new one right now.
Okay.
This job came to us from the de facto leader of the Rubicon
Liberation Front.
Let's see what it says, Raven.
This is Middle Flatwell, Liberation Front Central Icefield
Command.
We and the Belius Command are ramping up against the
corporations on two fronts.
Yeah.
At present, our primary concern is the seizure of PCA
hardware.
by the corporations.
The outsiders have the expertise and the resources to
reverse engineer PCA technology.
They're hungry too.
Hungry enough to consume the PCA whole.
This leads me to my request.
What is it?
The PCA have stationed LC's and a new model, the HC.
And those are taking less missions of...
I want you to obliterate them in order to...
What's it called?
Instruct- not instructor.
It's my handler.
Raven, I await your favorable response.
Taking less- one last jobs.
The- for my handler.
It's mostly from other people now.
But...
I'll destroy the LC's.
It's exceptionally rare to get a direct request for a
liberation from me.
But like, it's hard?
Perhaps the situation has changed their attitudes
That's right.
I'm a pretty important person.
I don't know if you know this, but I beat the rank one guy.
Mr. Fraud Man.
Alright, let's just kill him.
There was no reason for me to, but just wanted to send a
little message.
Alright, let me just rerun this.
I'll leave the question of where to strike first in your
capable hands.
I'm just gonna stop, keep riding.
Let it ride!
Well, I didn't want to shoot this guy.
Oh, wait, wait, wait a minute.
Oh, wait.
It's, oh my god, he's the boys.
I was like, don't worry.
I'll just one shot him.
I didn't realize they seemed a lot smaller.
and I thought oh my god oh my god okay one down okay this
guy you're next oh shit you're so lucky you have
reinforcements add reinforcements wait there's another guy
attending fee one they got the lcs wait who's this third guy
i didn't even notice a third guy for some patchwork ac the
hc line is reserved for elites impacts cutting edge
technology there we go all right guy number three down
Yeah?
Damn right, I do.
Cutting edge.
So that's where you came from.
Really cut his edge.
Oh wait, that's it?
Oh that was easy.
That's right.
So cutting edge.
Didn't even finish his dialogue.
Skipper.
Not important enough for me to hear your story.
So unimportant.
So fucking weak.
I skipped your plot line.
I skipped your entire character development.
And chase the freedom you never knew.
The others are so used to fighting and shouting slogans.
That they've given up sinking.
but flatwell he's exploring a potential for something new
yeah
where's he exploring i know he's gotta do these we haven't
fucking gone to the worm yet hey buddy this job comes from
schneider of the archibus group here's the rundown they want
you to attack the yorgon refueling base a pca foothold on
rubicon the target is the energy refinery plant deep inside
take that out and well it ought to slow down their
suppression fleet at least until recently Yorgon was one of
Baylam's coral survey bases it only took a day for the PCA
suppression fleet to commandeer the base you'll also find a
number of fuel storage to
I don't need to do that extra missions though
Try to skip But these Since they're like The the briefings I
feel like I should We're gonna be listening I think about
third time When we play this the third time it's gonna be
the same thing again I'm gonna skip the briefings Because
I've listened to these before Just focus on getting the job
done
Yeah I was just like wait a minute I don't remember this I
don't remember remember this.
Guys, I'm not listening to those briefings a third time.
That's for sure.
No, I meant the briefings.
No, no, no, no.
Because I was like, wait, you said this.
This feels like deja vu.
Whoops.
I'm very stealthy.
No, it's fine.
You should do our best to take the note.
I'm sure I've stockpiled my...
Apparently my money came with me when I, uh, Isakai back.
Are you serious?
It's not- It's not fair!
Thank God my money travels with me when I die.
Don't worry, my ancestor burned up millions of dollars so I
can carry this to my afterlife.
I'm gonna get rid of these guys.
Oh my god, I won't get rid of this guy.
Really?
That's, I'm gonna kill you specifically just because you did
that.
There you go.
We're gonna have to go this way just because...
Or I'll fall to my deaths.
Alright.
So fast.
I'm fastest.
I'm fast as fuck, what?
What are these guys doing up there?
Okay, now I can go back up.
That's the refinery plant.
Two and six to one.
I'm trying my best.
It's so far.
It's my entire purpose.
Why does it have to be so far?
All right.
Nice.
Our work here is done.
Wait, wait, wait, not yet.
Not yet.
Let me kill a couple of more.
Let me make a couple of more orphans today.
Oh, yeah, these guys.
Oh, shit.
The cops.
Oh, fuck.
I forgot the cops are here.
Oh, shit.
Maybe I should clear the waves.
Who got the cops on me?
I said no witnesses.
Oh, no.
Fence!
Scatter!
Oh my god, forgot how fast they are, dude.
Okay, where are they?
Hey, where are they?
PCASP machines.
They're highly mobile executioners for priority targets.
Boom!
Oh yeah!
Someone cheated on their entrance exams!
Boom!
Oh, this one is a little more tankier.
Don't quit your day jobs.
Cops.
Someone ate a little bit too many donuts.
Cat outrun the wheelchair.
Can't thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ever try Metal Wolf Chaos?
Never heard of that game.
It's also from Soft and, like, A6.
I've heard of that.
The U.S.
president in a mag jug.
GZ1 liners.
Wait, that's basically me right now.
In every way.
The first playthrough is this versus second playthrough.
That's right.
The cops can't even stop me now.
It's all over.
Archivist Group mercenary liaison.
V8 Pater here.
Impressive work on the refueling basis.
The four has left me a message addressed to you.
If I may.
Yeah?
I knew you could do it, buddy.
Whoa!
No, you're taking me blush, Rusty!
Oh!
We at the Archivist group expect more from you.
Oh, Rusty!
Oh my god.
Now I'm gonna kill him.
We've received a job from the Rubicon Liberation Front.
Let's take a look at the request.
We have a mission we'd like to offer you.
The Rubicon Liberation Front is planning to retake the wall
from Archibus.
And would like you to lay the groundwork for us.
Your objective is to assassinate V7 Swinburne, the commander
of the occupying force.
Winburn has dispatched surveillance squads to monitor for
intruders and hired operatives.
If our plan to retake the wall is to succeed, you must not
be spotted.
We're counting on you to handle this discreetly.
That's pretty easy.
Discreet is my middle name.
Oh, my perfect job for me, guys.
They all know how discreet I am.
am oh the lobotomy man oh it's the lobotomy emblem man
the camel will hide me perfectly like it has always done
don't worry guys it's not my first discrete rodeo
watch out for the surveillance I get a read on you.
This operation is over.
If you pick up the capture from your trap, take cover or
quickly destroy it.
Man.
Oh, it's this one.
I hated this one, actually.
I gotta focus up, guys.
I gotta focus up and kill everybody, guys.
I'm not gonna just drive by through that, guys.
My camel will blend me in perfectly.
There's nobody hiding here, at least.
Look at this guy.
Fuck that one guy in particular, though.
That one guy that was just chilling.
I've detected an AC in combat mode.
That must be Swingburn, the target.
All these lawless robes They never learn, do they?
Why the bottom me, man?
Where are you?
This isn't how the Liberation Front builds their AC.
Okay, I gotta make sure I don't kill him too fast.
Which is the hardest part.
This is our opportunity.
Alright.
I can't pile Bunky or you'll die too fast.
That's the thing.
You're so lucky.
I legitimately cannot pal-bunk you.
Or you're actually just dead.
Or you'll disappear.
I don't know where I'll put you up to this.
But clearly you need to be disciplined.
I'm actually...
I have to.
I'm Swinburne.
I can't lose.
Yeah, you are.
You know what?
Fuck yeah, I'll do this.
I gotta hold back.
You're...
So lucky right now.
Oh, I could pile punk you right now.
Oh, you're so pile punkable right now.
Oh, oh, oh, my God.
You're so submissive and power pile punkerable.
Oh, I'm only.
All right.
Let's not do anything hasty.
You realize I lead the Vesper 7th squad, which means I hold
the purse strings.
Every single transaction goes through me.
Yeah.
Let me go.
And you'll still come out on top.
Sure.
Do I accept, guys?
You're quick on the uptake, aren't you?
Splendid.
I'm sure Snail will see you're properly honored for this.
You're not like those savages.
Keep up the good work.
Alright, goodbye.
And he leaves.
I could kill him.
Whoops
I thought I was just I was just gonna watch him go.
Okay now I can power bug this guy though
All right now that's over with
Look it I need a power bump somebody.
Oh shit.
You're so lucky.
I have to You're so lucky.
You're too far away.
Oh My god, that was not that was an accident.
That's what I wanted to do
You're so lucky
You're so lucky I shot you so far away
All right, it's fine
Come on, get over here.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
Oh, that's it out of here.
Get pound-bunkered, old man.
Get your ass out of here.
Oh, is his name?
Is he Haiku, man?
I didn't even notice he was speaking haikus.
NSD, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
When a target in this mission asks to be spared, let him go
for the new ending.
Thank you, super chat, thank you, thank you, thank you,
thank you.
Let him put up a shield, agree to his terms, let your
instincts take care of the rest.
I thought I'd fuck up.
I thought I'd get too bloodthirsty.
How's it going, Walter?
Hard to say.
guys you don't understand I was restraining myself just in
case I was asking about you Walter bigger things the coral
you better find it turns out our friends fears were
warranted don't spend too long dealing with the PCA Walter
All right
Doesn't seem too bad
Two new messages It's hard to turn it off turn off the mercy
button Archivist group mercenary liaison V8 Peter here I
understand you spared V7 and destroyed a liberation front AC
That's me The company has allocated you an appropriate
reward as I'm sure you've noticed that Swinburne's shameful
conduct has dishonored the Vespers.
He has now been sent for re-education under the orders of V2
Snail.
That is all.
Another guy that I think is imagining a different stream.
In his mind, it's a different stream right now.
Registration number RB23.
I think this is the guy that just went through Lobotomy.
You may now test updates to Mind Alpha and analyze corporate
AC technology.
We look forward to your continued assistance in all minds'
drive toward perfection.
It's time to re-educate this viewer.
Whoops, I hackled.
I didn't mean to report it in.
I think he had three streams open and he thought this was
the chat to the other stream.
was talking to.
Oh, it's another split.
Alright, which split is this one, guys?
Which one did I've done before?
Destroy the special force craft or eliminate the PCA
enforcement squads.
But yeah, while you guys figure it out, I'm gonna use the
bath rub right back.
I'm back.
J-Lacone Z, Duck, NSD, Reels, Cyber, Solid, Mike, NXE, Bite,
Iron, NetBears, Medi-Allen.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, is it this one?
Destroy the Special Forces craft?
Is that the new one, guys?
I gotta be sure.
Yeah?
Alright, here we go.
New mission time!
Oh my god, we're actually speedrunning this.
This would take me five.
streams let's see what it says we have a mission would like
to offer you the PCA has deployed the catafract a special
forces weapon specialized for ground combat if we allow the
corporations to seize this kind of technology things will
take a dire turn glad to see doki not be filtered by the
first boss of the game um I actually even first tried the
first boss In reality, they used to chat that you think,
yeah.
It incorporates a bipedal MT as its core, making it a highly
versatile threat.
That MT core is also its vulnerability.
Focus your fire there, and it can be beaten.
You're our best chance.
What do you say?
I'll say how much does it pay?
Oh, 300k?
I'm in.
Enough said.
I've heard enough.
I'm in.
Main system.
Activating combat mode.
All right, here we go.
Commence mission.
Destroy the PCASP machine cataphract.
The fuck?
Ooh, shit.
What the fuck?
Code two three.
Enemy agency compressed.
what the fuck oh my god how do i destroy it where is this
weak point oh there i made my weak point it's right there
i'll make my weak point
oh shit did anyone get the license number
How dare he run me over when I stood in front of him?
How dare he?
There we go.
All right, easy.
It was a hidden gun.
That's right.
Easiest paycheck of my life.
Oh,
I'm business.
Business adult things.
You know, because I'm a businessman.
And I'm an adult man.
Easiest 300k I've ever earned.
why did that look easier than I remembered skill diff huh
I'm just a naturally born gamer
not a lot of people are you know lucky enough to be born
like me maybe we can beat the corporations and the PCA
all right nice that's how we win you hear that that's how we
win
This is a personal request from a friend.
However this.
We still don't have enough data to pin down where the coral
is gathering in the ice field.
According to my friend's sources, we could find some clues
here.
Asylum.
A city floating on the ocean, built by the Rubicon Research
Institute.
Ever since the fires, that place has been abandoned.
It's likely hiding secrets about the coral, kept shrouded by
the city's ECM fog.
My friends already tried sending in a survey drone.
Yeah, but you didn't send me in.
You should have sent me.
I was going to skip it, but then I don't remember exactly
this briefing.
I want you to disable the ECM fog.
I think it was like two months ago when I played this
mission.
Yeah, but...
I was just like, okay, I don't really remember this.
It's been two months.
All right, let's go in.
I mean, to be fair, Walter's not really talked to me much in
the second run, I feel like.
It's a little refresher.
I think it was mostly, like, everybody else telling me what
to do except for Walter.
Walter's just like, what the fuck are you doing?
And I was like, oh, nothing I just got to do some errands
for them, my wife.
That's it.
Oh, I remember this mission.
I was very lost.
Okay, I needed to follow these.
I remember now.
Where's the next beacon?
Okay, that's the next one.
Yeah, I remember them.
I had to follow this beacon.
And...
Oh, yeah.
And then there's...
the bombs.
Oh, I've just skipped the bombs, though.
Does it really matter?
Okay, it matters here, though.
It matters here.
It absolutely matters here.
There's another bomb.
Eh.
Are this way...
Intrusion attempt persisting.
This way...
Where?
Oh, shit!
There!
Oh my god, remember now.
Oh, I remember these guys.
Oh fuck
Just half in the cover
What the fuck who shot me?
Oh, you oh I remember you all this is I oh I all these guys
are so hard to hit It's this way
Oh, now it's the snipers too
Fuckers, I don't!
I don't!
This should be an optional mission.
Two repair kits remaining.
Where do I go from here?
Oh, it's this way.
Oh, fuck off!
Fuck off!
Whatever.
You're not important to me.
Ah!
Whatever.
Okay.
Are you serious?
Who are you?
I'm trying to!
Oh my god, they're all of them too.
Oh my god, they're a little fucking accidental rocket jump.
I'll just stab you.
I know you're like one HP, but I'll stab you.
Oh, where are you?
This happened last.
Run, too.
It's rewind time.
Let's check it out.
Okay, this way.
What?
Oh, my God.
I'm just jumping all around.
You're still following me, you fucking freak.
Are they already examining him?
Okay.
I swear to God, if I that guy's still there behind me.
I was just wondering if he's following me.
Oh, now you're telling me.
Oh, it's already here.
I don't know what else I could do.
about that.
Maybe I'll do this and then and then oh my god okay let me
get rid of the snipers real quick.
Oh I forgot about this.
All right it's fine it's fine go do your thing oh my god!
Do your thing!
Oh my god!
Okay, it's fine.
Oh yeah, because last time I didn't turn any of these guys
on.
Okay, now they'll be helpful.
Okay, now I don't have to fight them myself, at least.
This guy, mine?
This guy's mine.
Friendly fire.
I already legit forgot.
And then last guy.
Spirit of God, if all my guys already died.
Oh my god, the sniper's still fucking alive?
Get this guy out of here.
Oh, he's so lucky.
There we go.
Now it should just be the helicopter left.
No!
Damn, Becky.
My youngest body.
Yes, Becky's so fucking high up.
I'm trying!
I can't reach him!
He's so high up!
I'm trying.
I can't fly high enough.
Oh my god, whoops.
Get down from here!
Make this wheelchair accessible!
That's it.
Guys, guys, because I stabbed it.
Sab!
I did it, guys.
What do you mean?
I stabbed him.
Did you not see me stab?
him i don't know what you're talking about there was a stab
in there
fly iris and i can't i'm too fat i'm a chud i'm a chud i'm a
chud Ooh.
No new messages.
Raven.
The city's defense systems were still in operation after all
this time.
Does that mean I'm doing a good job?
The PCA personally intervened to block the survey.
There must be more to Xylem and to Wilter's friend.
Oh,
new arena.
finally more money oh this is where they integrated the
analysis yeah i can find two more arenas now all right here
we go it's arena time baby integration program initiating
phase two it's machine ai learn time please begin by
engaging the revised model mind beta in virtual
commencing analysis
Wait, they added armor spikes to his neck.
Oh my god, he's turning emo.
Oh my god.
No!
Not the fumble pit!
My trauma!
Why must we fight where my trauma is?
Oh my god, this AI knows.
This AI knows I have trauma here.
He knows.
Try hit me where it most hurts.
Stop dodging.
Oh, my God.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, he's so...
Oh, my God.
What the fuck happened to me?
Yes!
Quick jab.
Okay.
Into the bubble pit with me.
He is machine learning.
It's alright.
I learned too.
Surprisingly.
That's the biggest plot twist.
What if Doki...
They'll never account for the fact that Doki is also
learning.
Alright.
Now I can buy the last damage mitigation.
I don't even know what to do after.
that I guess more hacking speed I feel like I have like
everything I need
oh what do I even upgrade now quick turn I
have everything I have a salt we don't use a salt armor we
use pulse armor what I don't use kinetic weapons though
should we do axe i'm gonna grab this just for fun just to
hack better
all right next arena
is my pile bunker kinetic is it i thought it was melee or is
it both the next sample is the corporation ac this will be
integrated into mind beta can it be both
Commencing analysis.
Main system activating combat mode.
I don't know what they do to him.
Is he still a fucking annoying fly?
Oh my god, he's a little fucker.
He is still annoying fly.
He is absolutely...
Oh my god, they...
Oh my god!
There we go.
Okay, they need to they need to improve this guy, though
Target destroyed Including analysis well done Alright, easy
Explosive wind charge already have that I've exploded I mean
Big boom was the very first thing I upgraded guys.
I think I'm all set on that Alright last guy Get in here.
All your brothers and sisters are dead now.
You're not special.
I didn't say the best for last.
You were just a necessity to the end game.
Integration program.
Phase 2.
Final analysis.
The next sample is the Rubiconian AC.
This will be integrated into Mind Beta.
Alright.
this
main system activating combat mode okay
oh you're just gonna tank it oh I like I like that maybe you
didn't integrate a fucking idiot into the system it'd be
okay that guy was my number one fan he's really really
wanted to shake my hand guys
My god, she must have integrated a dragoon in there.
He got blinded by fangirling.
Oh my god, is that dookie?
Oh my god, I need to shake her hand.
Me, when I mean dookie, I've always spontaneously combust
after shaking her hand.
Whoops.
I hope that wasn't important for your continued support yeah
that's how all meet and greets go knowledge that can only be
gleaned from pitting two humanoid weapons against each other
all minds evolution is just there for the meet and greet
guys I wonder why even upgrade at that point I feel like
because like we don't use kinetic or do we use terminal
terminal armor maybe I guess it's like second life, so I'll
just grab that.
I have 17 more.
Oh,
is it?
Alright, I'll do quick turn.
I don't use these.
That's the thing.
I use pulse armor.
I lose my current one to do it.
What even is my current one?
manual aiming if you're if you're crazy okay let's not uh i
guess we got everything we need i guess at this point it's
just oh power bunker is kinetic i mean i'll just put it in
now we'll see if it does boost the damage
it doesn't really matter i got everything i need upgraded so
i just spent it just so i could spend it on something
already maxed out uh melee anyway it's just me putting stuff
in because i have nothing else to upgrade to become their
lackeys now they're feeling ambitious and sniffing around
rad territory again
calls for fireworks and i've got something that'll blow them
away the coyotes can't be ungrateful though they're bound to
come running to stop the launch that's where you come in
intercept them and defend the missiles oh no not this again
i'm skipping the briefing skipper skipper i know what this
is i okay so i remember i fucked it up
Hopefully the dozers won't be too difficult.
Skip the skip the that's there.
Here we go again.
I played these games before.
It's skip a skip a time.
Oh shit.
I remember I sort of trolled this one.
I know.
And I remember trolls doing a little hee hee hae.
Haha.
Are you still alive?
Alright.
I sort of... I don't remember what I did.
I just knew I was up.
Might not have been playing optimally.
I don't remember how I fucked up.
I just know I was not optimized.
Never thought they'd end up palling around with the PCA.
Smart, but not for long.
Here comes the second wave.
Keep the fireworks safe.
They're coming from the front by the side.
They just set free.
That's what I like to see, Taurus.
All right, we got these guys.
I just pity the poor fools.
Oh, my God.
I fucking, did you guys, did you guys see that?
He stood right in front of me.
Okay, where are these guys shooting at though?
I see you.
I don't think I didn't see you there.
They're coming from the bridge.
They are?
Oh, they are.
Don't let them slip past you.
We got one last shot!
Is he still alive?
He's not.
No, it's not.
Wait, what?
He just exploded?
No, he's just dead.
Okay.
Oh shit, how the fuck did he get over there?
What the fuck?
I didn't breach the defenses
The bridge Oh, not this goddamn toy box Oh, shit, I did not
take them out Sorry, instruction's unclear, instruction's
unclear Apparently I did not take them out first
Okay, you there, you You Missile launch sequence at 50%.
Chatty's almost ready.
Don't fail us now, Taurus.
You're coming from three directions at one.
Three directions!
We got more toy box mechs.
Oh, no one direction.
I get it.
Yeah.
My shoulder ammunition at 50%.
No!
Oh my god, he was literally one shot.
It's fun.
Two more minutes.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
What you didn't say anything, Carla?
What the fuck?
There's an entire army in front of us.
You didn't say anything?
Where is the intel?
Oh, yeah, this is where I fucked up.
This right here is how I fucked it up.
I remember now.
Not again!
Okay.
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine, that's fine, that's
fine, that's fine, that's fine, that's fine, that's fine,
not again.
Okay, that was close.
That was...
Dejavu.
It's not fine.
There we go.
Alright, look at that.
Just as easy as I remembered.
Maybe you should consider it a bill with better mobility.
That's like telling me to fucking watch.
I didn't choose this life.
You know what?
That's Alba's of you.
You think I just...
You think I'm miracles gonna happen?
I looked at it.
You did choose this life.
Oh, oh.
Just because I'm on a wheelchair.
You think this is a choice?
That's fucked up, bro.
You might need to go get P.I.
training.
So I hear.
Must be a tough time to be the Vesper's deputy commander.
Get to the point.
The plan to raid the PCA.
You're going to need more pawns on the board.
Of course.
You're here to hawk your services again.
Very well.
I'll consider that mutt of yours.
Part of the effort.
One more thing.
Show my hound some respect.
Gen 4 is as good a pedigree as any other.
Yay!
One new message.
What are those, like, training calls when you're at, like, a
company and you have to, like, go through?
Uh...
Thanks for helping with the fireworks show.
The chief loved working with you.
Making sure you don't...
Making sure you're, like...
That's all I had to say.
Later.
Not insensitive to people.
No, not orientation.
No, no, no.
Like, is it PR training?
No, it's not PR training.
When you get marked up.
Sensitivity training.
The brainwashing.
Yeah, you might need to do sensitivity training.
seized by planetary closure, ministry, and destroy all.
Oh, this one again.
This one's hard.
That's right.
Can't believe it.
You told me to just get out of my wheelchair and just start
walking.
Someone needs to go to sensitivity training for that.
This is V2 Snail.
I shall brief you on the operation.
Under my direct authority.
Consider it a rare privilege.
We will conduct simultaneous surprise raids on two planetary
closure and restoration bases.
Rusty, my homie who I'll never betray or shoot in the back
where it's slowed twice on.
I'll never betray you.
V4 Rusty will be dispatched to handle the Hall of Base.
will be to disable their network and prevent support from PC
elite squads.
Raven, during this time, you must destroy all the heavy
warships birthed as a spaceport.
Oh, God, I hated this one.
I don't...
This is the one where, like, there was 20 ships, right?
Solid plan, but there's a catch.
Disruption of PCA comms won't last long.
I'll come support you when I finish it on my end.
I did not like that mission.
There was a lot of shit.
I could spam, right?
I can spam the...
I don't remember.
Was it this one where I could spam the thing?
No, it wasn't.
It wasn't.
This is the one where I can't spam it.
Because some of them are docked.
Yeah, this is the one where the ships are docked.
Okay, I'll just kill this guy.
now oh now they see me i really care about you guys though
oh wait wait a minute wait a minute you're oh shit whatever
oh my god they're all here estimated threat range three to
four contain the target I mean, I can take this.
Yeah, yeah, this is a different one.
I know it's not, because I remember the other one was like
Endgame.
I remembered.
So I know that for this one, I have like Gokkin.
Alright.
I snipe this one.
Oh my god.
Come on.
Let me, let me, come on.
Just poke.
Come on, just let me poke at it.
Don't be shy now.
All right, last one's all the way over there.
I don't think it's very smart to put three of your warships
side by side.
Might not be the smartest thing they've done.
Oh, where are you going to shoot me?
I haven't really been very good at that part.
Maybe I'll shoot you back.
It's right over here.
There we go.
Who shot me?
They shot me?
Sorry, I stood under it.
I might have stood under the warship.
I got distracted.
He shot me.
It can happen to anybody.
I can't believe I got shot.
That was crazy.
Oh my god.
That should hit him.
That doesn't kill him?
Okay, that should kill him.
Company 621.
In front of the base.
Oh, this way.
He was right.
Alright.
Ah, shit, the popo.
Hmm.
No.
Disengage.
This!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
There we go.
There's the other one.
Oh, there it is.
Whoops.
You know what?
Fuck, y'all tank it.
Oh, shit!
Do not take the missiles!
famous last words
I was not made for this I might be a tank but sometimes you
just can't tank all of it
Surely I could take a ship that's 20 times bigger than me
Rusty!
Looks like we've got high ranking PCA officers.
Oh my god, he's so cool.
He's like a dragon.
Oh my god.
I look so beautiful next to him.
I'm like that ugly friend they invite to make the average
friend look prettier.
It's like the cheerleader effect or whatever.
Or whatever it's cause.
I learned that and how I met your mother.
There we go.
One down.
Where's the other guy?
Is he on Rusty?
Rusty, I got my one.
Rusty?
Did you get your one?
It doesn't look like it.
Don't worry.
Your bro's getting my backpack, Rusty.
I'll boost you
Don't worry, Rusty He's in my backpack now
Damn, Rusty, you're showing your rage right now Pretty Rusty
What?
Second marker?
Oh, it's over there.
I was like, Rusty, do you know where it is?
What is that?
Oh my god, it's the worm.
It's the fucking worm.
Oh my god, he's here.
Now you show up.
I've been wondering where the fuck the worm is.
The worm.
It's the worm.
Oh my god, he's here.
Oh my god.
He's playing Garrio with me.
He's going to eat me up.
Is this a Garrio?
Don't worry, I'll stay up here.
Oh my god, he's looping me around.
Oh my god, he's trying to eat my points.
I played a Garrio.
I know what to do.
Sorry, Slitherio.
I was thinking about Slitherio.
The Alaskan bull worm.
Same thing.
Agario, Slitherio.
They eat you.
All our EOs in the end.
Exactly.
They're all EOs.
Eat and get big.
Now?
I'm way ahead of you.
I'm ready back home.
Don't worry.
I'm already back home.
Ready to relax.
Here's the situation, 621.
After the PCA SIGVAN Institute- I'm skipping this.
I already know everything I need to know about the worm.
Two new messages.
Erred the news, tourist.
Yeah?
I swear, huh?
You just keep dripping up over the Institute's relics, don't
you?
Well, I got something that might interest you.
Sent you a briefing.
Sorry to impose on you, Raven, but I've just sent you an
urgent request.
I wish we could deal with this on our own, but we've got no
choice but to count on you.
Take a look and see what you think.
All right.
at it again time to kill the worm again all right limit it
on this brute a dozer all right time to do the filler
missions first before we kill the worm yeah it's new game
plus
this is about the ice worm that institute relic you had a
run in with this filler tab if it were just the pca they
were teaming up against
other story.
You can't just throw bodies at it.
Clearly she doesn't know my strategy.
All I do is throw bodies at it.
She hasn't learned yet.
She thinks I'll change my strategy.
I am an immovable force.
You'll be heading to grid 012.
Hit the bodies, hit the worm.
Is there a quick, quick, so-so guy?
Is that him?
Oh, it's gonna be quick, quick, quick, quick.
Goes by the name of honest brute.
His AC milk tooth was built by us.
So it's only flaws that it's piloted by him.
When he ran from RAD, he didn't just take credits in tech.
Okay, I remember this.
I'm skipping that.
I literally remember it.
That part is where I remembered everything.
Now we're at one and a half months, guys.
It's filler rock now.
It's flame flurrier, man.
That's good.
He needs to get close to me.
Oh, wait.
That's bad.
I forgot he blinded me.
Never mind.
I forgot the fact that he fucking blinded me with the that
too.
Never mind.
Might not be as good as I remembered.
Oh shit!
Let me just take everything.
When you go down, where's the down after that?
Where?
That damn freaks using my toys like they were there make
sure you keep clear of the laser sensors oh i forgot about
that too a new friend from abroad just for me what joy
brings you to my beating heart yeah oh my god what hit me oh
my god
okay it's down here
Yeah, I'm just gonna shoot down.
Oh, I'm not gonna make it.
I gotta go.
Go this way.
I'll make it here.
I hate to see my babies get scrapped like this, you know?
Well, all right.
Smash them up.
They'll help me with my R&D.
AP at 50%.
Yeah, be over here.
Hello.
all right it's fine we're gonna get over to you and give you
a little handshake oh my god it's meet and greet time oh
shit oh fucker I almost went straight down I almost oh I
almost got me he's almost got me Oh, yeah.
I remember this one all too clearly.
Okay, this one.
Whoops.
This one.
And then...
Uh...
Whoops.
There you go.
I already got opened this, so...
I'll kill him just because I can.
Yeah, because I already opened, yeah.
So all the chests are open already.
anyway.
Where'd I go?
Oh, down.
Whoops.
Does this go through?
Where are the others?
Hoop.
Uh.
Alright, this way.
Hoop.
Alright.
Jump down there and we've got him cornered.
And then...
This is where he lives.
Alright.
Flamethrower guy.
Oh, yep.
There he is.
He's gonna be like...
Surprise!
Oh, the fucking good thing I couldn't make it.
Good timing on my part.
Just...
Oh my god!
Oh, it's just like I remembered!
It's just like I remembered, guys.
Oh my god, I can't see everything.
Oh!
Just like the good old days!
There we go.
Oh, thank God.
I'm new game plus.
Thanks fucking God.
Just shoot it in the general direction.
I love that.
I feel like I'm playing mob arrivals all over again.
Wee-wee.
Don't you just love being blinded?
My favorite part.
All right.
We're going to...
when we killed the worm which I believe is for three more
missions left one new message
this is chatty stick RAD thanks for putting down brute the
chiefs already in the workshop tweaking the rail cannon and
I've never seen her happier to be at work that is all later
tourist all right goodbye chatty there's new mission Oh But
that's why I like to hear also.
I guess I should check what time my I have to fly tomorrow
too, which might be something I really need to know.
Okay.
All right, it's not too bad Because it depends on like I
should I should sleep early too
It is a lot faster this would take me four streams to get to
I checked.
We're okay.
I'm definitely heading to bed early, though.
It must be laying the groundwork to take effective control
over the entire planet.
They've dispatched two high-ranking independent mercenaries
to raid the dam.
High-ranking.
I think it ranks to anybody now.
You need to be ready to take on both ACs at once.
Astro Crown and Umbarox.
As you know, we have few cards to play.
Zanomic, thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
you i hope you had a great stream and welcome everybody
all right let's get me in there oh so funny that they that
they think they'll beat me but i'm not significantly
stronger oh oh oh so silly what silly guys they are Let's
get started, Raven.
This pilot, Cull Sign King, has an 89.6% mission success
rate.
Yeah?
I make it 80.
I'm going to make it 50%.
Overrocks is piloted by Chartreuse, an aggressive bulldozer
of unrivaled firepower.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, he baited me.
I shot that guy.
I thought he was the enemy.
all right
who do i want to kill first i'll kill him first he's closer
you see it's more annoying to kill so i'll do him first
that's me i expected to see attached to a hostile what the
fuck
Are you serious?
Wait, that's just like, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, this is
supposed to be a 1V1.
Oh my god, he just backs away.
You can just do that.
Okay, this is not fair.
This is not fair.
Oh, this is not fair.
This is absolutely not fair.
There we go.
What do you mean another AC?
That didn't happen before?
Hello?
What?
Raven?
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Wait, wait a minute.
You're here.
You're not supposed
Oh, no, wait, wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute,
wait a minute, this is not canon Wait, wait a minute, wait a
minute, oh, I should definitely, I should have went for the
ox first That the ox was significantly easier here.
They're dead.
Alright, we killed the ox first.
We killed Raven.
Okay, alright, now that we know we killed the ox first.
Okay, alright.
We are in a little bit of a dilemma.
go take care of the objective king I'll clip this one's
wings this is not fair this is a branch mission I'll support
you why is she flying she's a tank oh wait that was my build
from before oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god where
did she go this isn't great you're just a jet war you belong
in a museum not the AC
This is not fair!
Why do they all know how to fly?
AP at 30%.
Together, Chartreuse.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Chartreuse, withdraw!
Abandon your AC!
AC Ambrose destroyed.
Oh, this is not fair to me.
They can all fly!
I see.
No!
We're not here to take back the raiders anymore.
I...
How did he do that?
Did he bury me?
AP at 30%.
Oh, this is not good.
This is actually...
This is not good.
This is...
Oh,
this might be...
Oh, this might be a little hard.
This might be a little hard.
Oh, the 1v3 is a little rough.
Guys, now I don't know if I'm stopping the worm anytime
soon.
Maybe I'll just wait.
What am I doing?
Wait, what?
No!
It's not fair.
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
This is fine.
There we go.
Chartreuse, withdraw.
Offend on your AC.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I hate you.
I hate you!
I'm shadowing my Anakin right now.
Oh my god!
Okay, alright.
Oh, tough.
Oh, I wish there was a supply right now.
Oh, there she is!
The
Raven is a symbol of resolve.
I'm you I'm you I'm you but better yes yes yes dodge this
dodge this
That's right, you're an inferior copy to me!
That's fucking right.
You're an inferior copy to me!
Parry this, you faker.
No new messages.
Nobody wants to talk to me.
I've looked into Branch, the independent mercenaries who
attacked you.
don't have a fixed membership instead they maintain
independence and anonymity with a revolving I've always been
the right true Raven since the very beginning now it seems
they've left it to you to change I'm the upgrade I'm you but
a lot lot better you'll have to make a choice no one can
make for you when that time comes I thought you had to drag
on I can support you Raven My dragons can make my choices
for me.
Think for myself.
You're so funny.
Wheelchair supremacy.
I have a personal request to ask you.
Yeah?
It's about the Angabret Tunnel, which is to be shut down
after it was hit by a coral surge.
I want to go there and survey the area.
Even before the coral surge, that place had been all but
abandoned.
it's an old structure dating far back into the colonization
of Rubicon there must be items of interest from throughout
the planet's history there as
I'm sure you're aware I have no resources with which to pay
you but I can propose an alternative if you find any wrecks
left by the PCA you should try accessing them both the
corporations and the rubiconians are gathering data on pca
technology whatever you collect i can exchange for credits
and transfer the funds yeah okay that doesn't matter i
remember wait i remember this now all right this is where we
got lost right
i remember now this is where we got really really lost She
talked about collecting money for me, and I was like, oh
yeah, this area.
This one.
Let's get started, Raven.
It was a very, very deep tunnel.
We should be able to recover data from.
I'll send to the marker data.
We don't really need to grab anything, but...
what the fuck all right whatever you go burn whatever you
want we don't need the money data and can influence digital
equipment the effects of the coral surge must have brought
some of the racks back online all right let's see what we
can find Whoops.
Oh.
Stuck.
Tunnel stuck.
Yeah, we don't need to read this again.
We've done this before.
This is an illogical leader.
But this appears to be something exceptionally personal.
Unaware.
Thank God they're so stupid.
This way.
All right.
Scanny, scanny.
Oh, wait, I don't...
Not scanny, scanny.
I'm so glad this is turning into a profitable mission.
An older generation of a...
There we go.
Now, scanny, scanny.
Door stuck.
Hey.
We got speedrun this forest.
This seems to be the warning signs of the calamity.
Wait, you're still alive?
Wait, before it struck.
You were still alive.
Now off we go.
Alright, last one.
Oh god.
No!
I flew too close to the sun.
I'm about to...
But I got a little too excited
Just like old times
We're shot who's shooting me?
Whoops Who's looking blowing flames on me me if this outing
has made you think about rubicon's past or the nature of
coral then it was all worth it oh yay see look at that
easiest speed run of my life all right ten thousand dollars
me thank you thank you wife for your very hard-earned money
You worked so hard that 10k Thank you waifu You worked so
hard that 10k will buy me one coke I gave them the heavy
warship fleet in exchange bailips in charge of putting down
the beast They also offered some top Vespers Guess they
don't trust us Better than nothing I'll provide what support
I can to Yeah, you're mad scientists.
R-A-D or whatever.
And that hound of yours.
Don't underestimate 6-2-1.
That hound always delivers.
Yeah.
You are.
What kept you 6-2-1?
You're a famous mercenary.
Oh my god.
I'm so famous.
Line up, everybody.
It's time for the meet and greet.
It's time for the special handshake.
Alright, destroy the ice worm.
It's time.
Okay, we don't need a...
We know.
Alright.
What was it?
Is this needle?
Alright.
I'm ready.
I got my two missiles and my two needles.
Can I punch a worm?
I can punch a worm.
Can I...
I have to make sure.
I can definitely punch the worm.
I didn't remember how to do this.
Okay, it's my right.
It's my right gun.
In fact, you...
Oh, yeah, yeah, I remember.
I was just like...
I was like, how did I kill this rim?
Oh, yes, I punched it.
Whoa!
Yeah.
Oh, shit!
That's been a while.
Guys, you don't understand.
It has been so long since I punched the worm.
This is V4 Rusty.
Rail cannon is good to go.
Don't die before I get a chance to fire, buddy.
Tourist, got a message from the chief for you.
Enjoy the show.
And don't forget to smile.
Where is he going?
Oh, shit.
Okay, but he has to look at me if I want to Do any.
There we go.
Just like how I remembered.
There he goes.
Where is he?
I won't miss.
Oh my god, he's so cool.
I shall punch you!
That's how you punch the worm.
Oh, I thought I got it.
I could get it again.
He's so cool.
Oh my god, he's so cool.
I hope he lives a very long life after.
Oh my god.
Definitely a guy that's going to live a long, prosperous
life.
Nope.
One step ahead of you, Commander.
All right, where is he?
Where is he?
Come on up.
Oh, my God.
Where's the worm?
Where is he?
Oh, shit!
Boom!
Come on, Rusty, round two!
Round two, Rusty!
You can't miss the second one.
Imagine if he's not missed the second time.
Oh!
Secondary shield down.
It's all yours now, buddy.
Boom!
Oh shit, I forgot about this part.
Oh fuck, oh my god, I got him.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Okay, I still have one more.
Looks like things just took a nasty turn.
I'll set the award seat to maximum output.
We can't afford to lose control of the situation.
Oh shit, I thought- No!
Reloading!
No!
the reload again okay okay he's still alive my boy is still
here gaming my boy's still gaming keep
game down no he was right here it's I got too cocky I I got
so cocky, guys.
I got too excited.
Look at me!
Oh!
Oh, he didn't look at me.
It's fine.
I don't need that repair kit.
Rusty would have missed.
Well, why isn't Rusty here?
Huh?
Why is it rusty here?
I thought so.
Oh,
shit, bro.
Oh, my God, you got him.
If he's so cool, maybe he should have fucking...
Are you fucking kidding me?
The stupid ass worm.
Where is he?
Good work, buddy.
All email modules connected.
Energy turbines at full capacity.
I don't know where he's going to come from.
Please, please, I'm giving me a...
Please, I have nothing else!
Bye, Rusty!
Is it over?
It's cinema!
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit!
They're beautiful.
Shoot me.
The freelancer really did it.
I did it.
That's me.
All or nothing.
It's finally over.
Part two.
The blast can terminate the area.
Get out.
Get out of what?
Coral voices lost again.
Raven.
There's something I have to tell you.
What?
What is it?
The coral.
Something I've never heard of before.
It's my family.
Oh, really?
Really?
I've never heard of this information before.
They're all new to me.
No.
No one even knew I was there for such a long time.
Raven, you're the only one who.
Huh.
Me?
I told you I'm special again.
Go get your rest, 6-2-1.
Things are going to get busy.
I know I did.
Thank you, Walter.
Yeah, I'm pretty famous.
If you didn't know.
Yeah.
The temporary alliance between the Archibus and Baylam
groups turned the tide of war.
devastating the planetary closure administration forces and
exiling them from Rubicon.
Though it was the Ice Worm mission led by Balaam that dealt
the decisive blow, Archibus, through their own engagements
with the PCA, augmented their strength with seized weaponry.
As we watched this, was broken.
The scales tipped in Archibus's favor.
And the Rubicon Liberation Front's hopes of fighting an
exhausted foe were dashed.
Oh my god, to fight the worm a third time after this.
Just realized.
Not to fight the worm a third time.
And their bitter conflict burned with Renewable Tessie.
My god.
It's rewind, rewind time.
Forum, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The early bird gets the worm.
Doing okay, 621.
I'd wanted to let you rest.
Oh, that's true.
I'm now facing the right side.
I never thought I'd seen this.
I'm on the right side now.
Do you remember the survey you carried out at Silam?
My friend analyzed the data.
We learned about a massive facility under the central ice
field, or I'm thinking of the super chat that you think you
play the second ending I'm gonna call it here.
I'm getting tired Turns out that the ice worm was defending
the entrance to that place.
I think we're still like one or two at like two hours left
So we get to the second ending
Raven there's something you need to know that friend Walter
mentioned The comms database has no record of the
conversation.
He just told you about this isn't about just finding the
cool raven he's after something more and he's using you to
do it you're so right my wife you'll never leave me astray
whoa whoa sorry i had like a mini seizure there apparently
raven we have added new samples to the integration program
you may now test updates to mind beta and verify
reproductions of special acs we look forward to your
continued assistance in all minds drive toward perfection
all right how many arenas we have all right we're gonna call
it here guys i'm getting a little eepy now but it's been fun
we're almost there on the set to finish i think like i think
we need two more hours for the second ending but i'm gonna
call it here because i am getting pretty tired right now i'm
low getting my energy is getting depleted and then we do
have i i have a busy day basically fly and then go straight
to the game show.
So I have to have enough energy for tomorrow's game show
stuff and make sure I bring everything I need for it as
well.
Hey guys!
Thank you all for coming, guys.
As always have fun streaming for everybody.
And 7, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for streaming safe travels.
Thank you!
I'm super excited.
I'm gonna be visiting the Capcom office for the first time
too.
So I'm super excited to see what that's gonna look like.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked, get
up, move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up
for me head to bed guys you deserve it i'm gonna head off
now see you guys tomorrow uh we're gonna be multi uh
there'll be multi-streaming on my channel as well for the
game show so don't worry it'll be on the on the channel as
well i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye